schönen guten morgen und darf ich sie
bitten die plätze einzunehmen ich darf
sie herzlich begrüßen heute zur
präsentation der publikation risiko
landschaft österreich heuer ein bisschen
später als sonst aber dafür in einer
situation die ein ganz neues licht auf
viele der themen wirft den dieser
risikobewertung in den letzten jahren
als unwahrscheinlich als wahrscheinlich
da stand plötzlich tatsächlich realität
wurden wir diskutieren das heute und
präsentieren dass ihnen in den nächsten
zweieinhalb stunden ich muss sie bitten
die masken an zu behalten bei dieser
veranstaltung frau ministerin darf sie
herzlich begrüßen generalstabschef liebe
abgeordnete zum nationalrat und seine
oper eu-parlament lieber ehrengäste aus
verschiedenen branchen die heute hier
sind mein name ist corinna milborn ich
bin in frechen bei pro sieben sat eins
bis vier und plus 24 ich freue mich dass
ich sehe gerade in dieser spannenden
zeit heute wieder durch diesen vormittag
begleiten darf und darf zu beginn zur
begrüßung den hausherren auf die bühne
bitten generalmajor miliz beauftragter
und obmann der raiffeisen holding
niederösterreich wien erwin hameseder
bitte sehr
[Applaus]
guten morgen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren sehr verehrte frau
bundesministerin hier
generalstabschef
sehr verehrter herr abgeordneter zum
nationalrat meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren für mich ist es eine große
freude dass diese veranstaltung auch
heuer wieder in unserem haus
stattfindet und es wurde schon gesagt
risiko landschaft österreich 2022 in
einer zeit die vor einem monat wir noch
durchaus etwas anders beurteilt haben
und daher kommt dieser veranstaltung
heute aus meiner sicht als
sicherheitspolitisches parameter eine
für mich noch viel größere bedeutung zu
als sie sonst immer auch schon inne
hatte und
seit beginn des krieges in der ukraine
mitten in europa wer hätte dass meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren je
gedacht ein krieg der direkt vor unserer
haustür im wahrsten sinn des wortes
stattfindet ist immer wieder jetzt von
einer zeitenwende
die räte ja meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren der 24 die zweite ist der
beginn einer zeitenwende für uns alle
ich teile diese einschätzung
und was ende februar mit diesem
angriffskrieg in der ukraine passiert
ist stellt eine sehr tiefgreifende
erschütterung unserer europäischen
sicherheit ordnung da und die letzten
wochen haben sehr klar gezeigt krieg in
unserer nachbarschaft
kann niemals ausgeschlossen werden das
ist durchaus eine erkenntnis die
vielleicht uns nicht so präsent war aber
wir wissen dass jetzt und das beweist
sich und der krieg in der ukraine
und natürlich die sanktionen als massive
reaktion der west die welt gegen
russland haben dramatische auswirkungen
und zwar auf alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche
politisch sozial und ganz besonders auch
wirtschaftlich wo die erfolgen in
letzter konsequenz heute überhaupt noch
nicht absehbar sind
was ja heute und wir eigentlich schon
länger wissen wir müssen massiv in
unsere sicherheit investieren und damit
in unsere landesverteidigung es ist ein
gebot der stunde
dass regel pc so rasch als möglich
deutlich über ein prozent anzuheben und
zusätzlich auch sonde investitionspakete
bereitzustellen um die großen
versäumnisse in der vergangenheit
rasch nachzuholen die frau
bundesministerin und der
generalstabschef haben auch in
mittlerweile vielen öffentlichen
veranstaltungen
die sehr klar zum ausdruck gebracht
und als miliz beauftragter der frau
bundesministerin zeige ich auch die
wiedereinführung der verpflichtenden
milizübungen
ist ein ganz wichtiger baustein zur
herstellung der einsatzbereitschaft des
österreichischen bundesheer ist daran
müssen wir arbeiten da bin ich voll
überzeugt nur wer regelmäßig übt das
betrifft unsere miliz soldatinnen und
soldaten kann auch seine aufträge
erfolgreich
erfüllen
unsere nachbarn haben alle bereits auf
diese neuen dramatischen
herausforderungen reagiert und erhöhen
massiv ihre verteidigungsbudgets
und ich begrüße daher auch sehr die
immer wieder hörbaren einhelligen
zusagen der höchsten politischen
verantwortungsträger rinnen und
verantwortungsträger auch unser
verteidigungsbudget erheblich aufstocken
zu wollen
und über 60 prozent der
österreicherinnen und österreicher
wollen ein bundesheer das in der lage
ist die republik österreich zu
verteidigen nun kommt es auf das
konkrete handeln an
und seit beginn dieses furchtbaren
krieges mitten in europa ist es einfach
notwendig dass europa mit einer stimme
spricht
wir sind risiken ausgesetzt die neu sind
wir sind risiken ausgesetzt die in einer
dramatik zum ausdruck kommen die die
wirtschaft im wahrsten sinn des wortes
ganz massiv
erschüttern
was können wir dagegen tun
nun meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
wie auch von der wirtschaft sind
aufgerufen darüber nachzudenken wie wir
die republik österreich resident machen
können welche maßnahmen wie auch setzen
können und auch setzen müssen damit das
gelingt und das betrifft auch ganz
besonders das thema cyber abwehr und ich
sage ihnen aus erfahrung gerade in den
letzten wochen und monaten sind diese
cyber angriffe deutlich mehr geworden
das hat sich in den letzten jahren
aufgebaut aber mit dem jetzigen zustand
sind die letzten jahre dann nicht mehr
vergleichbar und das bedeutet für uns
auch in der wirtschaft einen unglaublich
hohen zusätzlichen aufwand wenn sie so
wollen
es geht um kosten und das wissen alle
vertreterinnen und vertreter der
wirtschaft ganz genau wir spüren daher
jeden tag aufs neue wie negativ der
krieg in der ukraine
abgesehen von den wirklich sehr
berührenden und dramatischen humanitären
folgen
wie wir da auf den globalen aber auch
auf den nationalen märkten getroffen
werden
österreich ist auch wirtschaftlich keine
insel sondern ganz im gegenteil die
österreichische wirtschaft ist weltweit
global vernetzt und erste
sehr grobe verwerfungen machen sich sehr
deutlich bemerkbar die letzter
konsequenz meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren sprechen wir da auch über den
allfälligen verlust von vielen
arbeitsplätzen
dabei geht es in letzter konsequenz auch
um die soziale sicherheit das sind alles
themen die uns alle
einen wo wir massiv dagegen arbeiten
müssen und bei allen notwendigen
reaktionen auf der europäischen ebene
durch die sanktionen das ist überhaupt
keine frage dass sie notwendig sind mit
vehemenz auch durchgesetzt werden müssen
gegen russland das ist eine klare
botschaft aber es soll und muss
weiterhin der grundsatz gelten dass
sanktionen uns selbst nicht mehr schaden
als demjenigen dem sie eigentlich gelten
sollen
und ich denke
genau das geht es
das ist politisch sicherlich sehr sehr
schwierig das ist eine gratwanderung das
ist uns allen bekannt aber ich betone
noch einmal in letzter konsequenz
muss es uns darum gehen europa darum
gehen aber auch national in der republik
österreich darum gehen dass wir
einerseits solidarität gegenüber dem
angegriffenen zeigen aber andererseits
genau abwägen wie weit ist das maß auch
für unsere österreichische bevölkerung
verantwortbaren tragbar das heißt die
verantwortung für die innere und die
äußere sicherheit ist sehr sehr groß und
ich bin überzeugt davon dass diese bei
unserer bundesregierung und gerade wenn
es um unsere landesverteidigung geht bei
dir sehr verehrte frau bundesministerin
höchst
verantwortungsvoll in deinen händen gut
aufgehoben ist alles gute für tatkraft
erfolg lassen sie uns gemeinsam
die hoffentlich richtigen
schlussfolgerungen
damit wir morgen auch sicher sind vielen
dank
[Applaus]
herzlichen danke hannes eder und ich
darf er zum die keynote
verteidigungsministerium bitten claudia
panama bitte
sehr geehrter herr präsident general
major release beauftragt
er will sehr geehrter herr
generalstabschef lieber robert sehr
geehrte damen und herren abgeordnete
generäle und festgäste vertreter der
medien
an einer ganz besonderen
tagung ich möchte danke sagen dir danke
sagen als hause als veranstalter aber
auch all denjenigen danke sagen die im
hintergrund auch heuer wieder dazu
beigetragen haben dass diese so wichtige
veranstaltung stattfinden kann
es ist bereits angesprochen worden der
24 februar das ist ohne zweifel eine
zäsur in der europäischen geschichte
besonders aber auch eine zäsur für die
europäische und österreichische
sicherheitspolitik
der angriff russlands auf die ukraine
der hat uns schockiert
die bilder fans tatsächlich unter die
haut sie machten uns unglaublich
betroffen er hätte es für möglich
gehalten dass der krieg zurückkehrt
zurückkehrt nach europa und dass das was
wir für selbstverständlich gehalten
haben nämlich den frieden dass dieser
keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr ist
das könnten wir uns denken wir wurden
überrascht
wir würden alle überrascht und wir
wurden auch getäuscht vielleicht ist das
so sehr geehrte damen und herren
müssen oder mussten wir überrascht sein
von dem was
passiert und was passiert ist
wenn wir uns zum beispiel den bericht
der sicherheitspolitischen
jahresvorschau 20 20 wie sie damals noch
genannt wurde also vor genau zwei jahren
anschaut diesen durch blätter dann
findet man im risikobild auch den punkt
russland in konfrontation zu europa vor
der punkt war schwarz in dieser skizze
er gehörte also zu jenen geopolitischen
oder geo ökonomischen risiken die auf
die eine oder andere weise zu einer der
genannten
risikokategorien werden könnte
und die jahres forscher dann dass ja
darauf 20 21 da findet man zusätzlich
beiträge zur krise in der ost ukraine
und zu russlands beziehungen zur
europäischen union
was ist nun also passiert
hat niemand diese
sicherheitspolitischen jahresvorschau
genau gelesen
hat niemand auf die
nachrichtendienste gehört
ich denke doch
bin überzeugt davon dass diese berichte
gelesen worden sind
und ja sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
waren trotzdem
überrascht
vielleicht weil wir es nicht glauben
können und wollen konnten und wollten
wir haben es nicht glauben wollen weil
wir in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
insbesondere in europa anderes gewohnt
waren viel anders das gewohnt waren es
ist doch etwas das nicht in unser ding
system
hineinpasst wir haben gänzlich andere
erfahrungen gemacht
ich glaube dass wir uns dieser wahrheit
stellen müssen und wir müssen vor allem
eines wir müssen die lehren für die
zukunft daraus ziehen
daher darf ich zunächst ein paar ganz
grundsätzliche worte zum aktuellen
bericht der risiko landschaft österreich
finden der zwar noch vor dem aktuellen
angriff auf die ukraine erstellt worden
ist der aber das thema russland und
ukraine natürlich trotzdem auf dem radar
hatte
es geht in dem bericht um die großen
geopolitischen und
verteidigungspolitischen zusammenhänge
die sich auf österreich und auf europa
auswirken können und rund um das
risikobild für uns in der nächsten zeit
die bedeutung von risiken die kann sich
ändern aber
ich glaube das ist ganz besonders
wichtig wir kennen die beziehungen und
die zusammenhänge dieser risiken wie das
entsteht wird heute in weiterer folge
noch von brigadier bitter vorhofer
ausgeführt werden
general ham se da hat das wort
zeitenwende
verwendet sie ist tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende das ist eine zeitenwende
auch in der internationalen
sicherheitspolitik
die ja eigentlich schon vor dem 24
februar begonnen hat denn wie wir aus
der geschichte wissen eine zeitenwende
die kommt oft schleichend die kommt oft
schleichend auch durch mehrere
ereignisse
man nimmt sie vielleicht nicht wirklich
war ich glaube das kann ein sehr gutes
gesprächsthema heute seien im weiteren
verlauf der veranstaltung
wenn wir uns die risken so
anschauen dann stellen wir fest es gibt
mehr als je zuvor sie kommen auch
geografisch immer mehr sie kommen immer
näher an österreich an europa heran
dinge die vor ein paar jahren noch als
undenkbar bei uns gegolten haben sind
entweder schon passiert oder zumindest
wahrscheinlicher geworden denn wer hätte
einmal gedacht daran dass eine pandemie
mit ihren vielen
kranken und toten den zahlreichen lockt
tanz und uns muss hier im so
vermeintlich geglaubten sicher in
österreich und europa heim sich suchen
würde und doch ist es passiert und wenn
ich hier in der unten sehen wir tragen
nach wie vor auch bei dieser
veranstaltung die masken wer hätte
gedacht sehr geehrte damen und herren
dass es nicht unweit von hier auch
passiert dass islamistische terror
anschlag schläge kommen und doch ist es
passiert und
ganz zu schweigen von dem was ihm zu
nehmen auch war die naturkatastrophen
die folgen des klimawandels dürren
stürme überschwemmungen überflutungen
cyber attacken
mit sehr wahrscheinlichen blackouts und
wie jetzt in der ukraine ein angriff
eines anderen landes mit klassischen
konventionellen militärischen
mitteln
was heißt das jetzt für uns was sind die
lehren daraus eine lehre glaube ich
spätestens aus der ukraine heraus ist
dass die konventionelle kriegsführung
nach wie vor realität ist und das
bedingt auch eine militärische
landesverteidigung die ja nach wie vor
unsere kernaufgabe die kernaufgabe des
österreichischen bundesheeres ist wir
sehen aber auch
andere mittel wie cyber attacken und
desinformationen wir erleben und spüren
wirtschaftliche druckmittel
und merken dass dies ebenfalls teile der
kriegsführung sind das heißt für uns
also das heißt für uns als
österreichisches bundesheer dass wir uns
zur verteidigung unseres landes sehr
breit aufstellen müssen
und daher benötigen wir
auch das ist schon angesprochen wurden
nicht nur heute
wir benötigen ein deutlich höheres
verteidigungsbudget und wenn ich ihnen
die rider abgeordneten schaue dann freue
ich mich wirklich darüber dass es dazu
einen überparteilichen konsens gibt und
es wurde auch schon angesprochen
generalmajor hannes eder die
österreicherinnen und österreicher die
bevölkerung die steht hier unter gibt er
uns das zeigen uns die aktuellen
wissenschaftlichen
umfragen und unser ziel ist es das
verteidigungsbudget auf eine
größenordnung von ein prozent des brutto
inlandsproduktes entlang dieses pfades
anzuheben um in weiterer folge in den
kommenden fünf jahren sukzessive auf 15
prozent zu erhöhen und dann eines tun zu
können den massiven
investitionsrückstau der ja ein bekannt
ist und der nicht nur die letzten jahre
sondern die letzten jahrzehnte betrifft
aufzuholen wir müssen unsere
militärischen kern kompetenzen und
fähigkeiten stärken und diese weiter
ausbauen und ganz offen konzepte die
gibt es genug
konzepte gibt es in unserem ressort
genug die sind vorhanden auch wenn das
eine oder andere mal ein kritiker eine
kritikerin anderes behaupten möge aber
jetzt geht es darum diese auch
umzusetzen und ich kann ihnen hier auch
eines versichern sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir werden nichts kaufen was wir
nicht benötigen was wir nicht dringend
benötigen das ist das eine
das andere aber dass wir schon allein
aus der pandemie lernen mussten ist das
für krisen breiter sehen müssen und dass
diese auch nicht nur durch ein einziges
ressort abgedeckt werden können
wir haben in zusammenhang mit dem
angriffskrieg sofort in der nacht ich
habe den anruf des herrn
generalstabschefs um 4 uhr 7 noch im
kopf den rücktritt an ich dachte
tatsächlich ich habe
nicht richtig gehört so ist es
wahrscheinlich dem einen oder anderen
gegangen wir haben dann sofort das
krisenkabinett eingerichtet
mit bundeskanzler an der spitze
außenminister
innenminister umwelt und energie
ministerium ich glaube das war ein
unglaublich wichtiger schritt und ich
sage auch ganz offen dass wir hier
regelmäßig sowie auch gestern tagen in
unserem als auch ein richtiges und
wichtiges zeichen und wir haben ja auch
bei der pandemie erleben müssen dass es
so verschiedenste ebenen gibt die
notwendig sind gelebt zu werden und das
ressort übergreifenden zuständigen
gremien das heißt wir müssen auf jeden
fall eine erhöhte gesamtstaatliche
residenz aufbauen oder ausbauen wir
sehen dass diese konflikte die krisen
komplexer werden und an diese
komplexität und an diese realität da
müssen wir unsere konzepte anpassen aber
wahrscheinlich auch unsere
begrifflichkeiten wir müssen den einen
oder anderen begriff wahrscheinlich auch
neu
interpretieren neu definieren wenn man
hier an die schlagwörter denkt wie
militärische landesverteidigung
wirtschaftliche landesverteidigung oder
geistige landesverteidigung das alles
sind offizielle begriffe die es ja schon
seit jahrzehnten gibt unter dem
oberbegriff der umfassenden
militärischen landesverteidigung aber da
geht es jetzt darum diese zu diskutieren
und auch zu beantworten wie insbesondere
der begriff der militärischen
landesverteidigung im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert zu deuten ist
beginnt dies wie in der entschließung
des nationalrats im jahr eins und 75 zum
damals eingeführten artikel 9a des
bundesverfassungsgesetzes ab der
staatsgrenze
oder wo werden freiheit demokratie und
wohlstand mit militärischen mitteln der
europäischen union und damit auch der
unseren verteidigt
worin besteht um wohlstand und sozialen
zusammenhalt auch anzusprechen die
wirtschaftliche landesverteidigung im
zeitalter von klimaschutz die
kolonialisierung und neuen energien
aktuell wie nie endet diese mit der
einsamen leitung mit der leitung zum
haus zur industrie an der zapfsäule oder
beginnt sie bei der sicherstellung von
roh- und grundstoffen etwas für künftige
große batterie und wasserstoff systeme
um die energiewende sicherzustellen
und wenn wir das mit ja beantworten wie
sichern wir dann wie sichert europa dann
den zugang zu solchen stoffen von abba
über den transport bis hin zu
europäischen fertigungsstätten und zu
den konsumenten zugleich andere mächte
das mit allenfalls
bewaffneten konflikten mitteln wird
mitteln versuchen zu ihren gunsten zu
beeinflussen oder zu beschränken
sehr geehrte damen und herren der
aktuell vorliegende berichte risiko
landschaft österreich 20 22 zeigt diese
risiken und zusammenhänge die noch im
detail heute dargelegt werden ich möchte
auf einen glaube ich ganz wichtigen
punkt noch eingehen und zwar den der
geistigen landesverteidigung
wie verstehen wir diesen wie wir stehen
wir diesen begriff in europa wie
verstehen wir ihn in österreich wenn wir
wissen dass eine äußerst geringe
bereitschaft den sehr breiten schichten
der bevölkerung besteht unsere
freiheiten
unsere interessen notfalls auch mit
militärischen mitteln mit der waffe zu
verteidigen wenngleich jetzt sind
eu-fragen krieg in der ukraine diese
bereitschaft kurzfristig
gebessert verbessert hat wie lang wird
denn das anhaltend ist das vielleicht
auch nur eine emotion geschuldet einer
emotionalen sichtweise oder gelingt es
uns gemeinsam das nach nachhaltig auch
aufrecht zu erhalten oder geht dann
irgendwann einmal die aufmerksamkeit
wieder wegfallen wir alle zurück in
österreich in europa in eine angenehme
bequemlichkeit die über jahrzehnte leben
durfte nun werden wir dann wieder
überrascht und unvorbereitet sein
wir müssen uns über viele gedanken macht
nicht nur hier in österreich sondern
auch international auf europäischer
ebene wie es weitergeht ob etwa der
multilateralismus so wie wir ihn kennen
und dessen organisationen wie zum
beispiel die uno die osze ebenfalls der
komplexität ob diese der realität des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts angepasst
werden müssen oder ebenfalls einer neuen
definition
unterzogen werden müssen
wir hatten gestern eine sehr
interessante veranstaltung in der
landesverteidigungsakademie unter
führung des französischen botschafters
und
haben uns über den strategischen konkurs
der europäischen union sehr intensiv
unterhalten wir haben festgestellt dass
da für österreich ein unglaublich
wichtiger meilenstein ist in der
weiterentwicklung der gemeinsamen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
gsvp dieses strategische grundlagen
dokument das ab zielt auf die abwendung
von hybriden bedrohungen das uns in die
lage versetzen soll und muss frühzeitig
auch bedrohungen krisen zu erkennen
er soll leitlinien vorgeben für die
maßnahmen der sich jetzt von
verteidigungs dimensionen um die
europäische union im sicherheitsbereich
stark zu machen um uns auch
handlungsfähig zu machen
wir in österreich wir werden uns auf
jeden fall weiter das haben wir ja schon
bisher getan aktiv sehr aktiv an der
weiterentwicklung der gsv beteiligen
immer natürlich im rahmen unserer
rechtlichen möglichkeiten und wir werden
wie auch bisher unser engagement im
bereich der gsv bei operationen aufrecht
erhalten wir müssen uns sehr anstrengen
wir müssen unsere eigenen militärischen
kräfte wie bereits angesprochen
finanziell aber auch personell und
materiell stärken um vor allem auch
einen glaubhaften beitrag zu leisten zu
einer besseren zusammenarbeit für ein
sicheres europa und ein sicheres
österreich
in zeiten wie diesen glaube ich auch
ganz gut mit einem durchaus positiven
ausblick auch zu enden wir müssen uns
bewusst sein dass wir jedes dieser
risiken grundsätzlich positiv
beeinflussen können
das heißt es liegt an uns wie wir diese
risiken gestalten es gibt einen
schlüssel in dem alles liegt das ist der
schlüssel in der zusammenarbeit das
verteidigungspolitische risikobild der
expertinnen und experten des
verteidigungsministeriums der externen
institutionen ergänzt auch um
gesamtstaatlich vertiefte analysen
spezifischer einzelrisiken wird und
davon bin ich überzeugt dazu beitragen
dass die wahrnehmung auf mögliche
kommende ereignisse auch geschärft wird
dass wir diese vermindern können ja und
im besten fall auch verhindern können
und an dieser stelle ein ganz großes
dankeschön an all diejenigen expertinnen
experten die mit beigetragen haben
zusammen aber dieser schlüssel wir
können mit sicherheit das alles nicht
alleine tun wir brauchen diese
zusammenarbeit zwischen den
verschiedenen fachrichtungen zwischen
den verschiedenen disziplinen auf
nationalstaatlicher und auf europäischer
ebene
wir brauchen die zusammenarbeit mit der
wirtschaft und allen anderen zivilen
partnern und akteuren es kann nur
gemeinsam gehen aber es geht ja auch um
eines geht ja auch um die sicherheit von
uns ein nur gemeinsam können wir
schaffen ein lebenswertes österreich und
ein lebenswertes europa zu bewahren ich
darf mich bedanken bei allen beteiligten
und bin überzeugt davon
das mit den heutigen beiträgen der
expertinnen und experten ein
erkenntnisreicher vormittag gesichert
ist und in jedem fall ein sicheres
österreich und europa für morgen ich
danke ihnen
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank frau ministerin für die
keynote systems ist ja ein sehr breites
risiko feld das er beleuchtet wird sie
haben wahrscheinlich so wie ich die
publikation zugeschickt bekommen und sie
soll jetzt zum download und wenn sie
sich da die ersten seiten aufmachen und
die grafik ansehen wo die verschiedenen
risiko punkte drinnen sind dann sehen
sie dass der krieg auf den sehr
logischerweise jetzt sehr konzentriert
center so der ukraine krieg einer ist in
der mitte unter sehr vielen anderen wir
haben jetzt für den inhaltlichen details
den wir anbieten wollen fünfter
autorinnen die die am höchsten
bewerteten am risikoreichsten bewerteten
punkte abdecken und die beiträge dazu
geschrieben haben in dieser publikation
und möchten zu beginn einen überblick
hören vom über leitungs verantwortlichen
in der direktion verteidigungspolitik
und internationale beziehungen im
verteidigungsministerium
brigadier peter vorhof hat er uns einen
überblick über die risiko landschaft
2022 bitten wird
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister meine
damen und herren liebe gäste
ich darf in den nächsten minuten einige
ausführungen zur einstellung eines
risikopuffers bzw zu einer strategischen
vorschau an sie herantragen sie können
sich vorstellen dass das
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
und die direktion für
verteidigungspolitik und internationale
beziehungen in den letzten monaten sehr
viel mit pro knoten ist prognostizierten
und eingetretenen risiken zu tun hatte
die frau bundesminister hat angesprochen
die überraschungen dies trifft sicher zu
auf die westlichen gesellschaften
vielleicht sprechen wir in zukunft über
eine phase von drei überraschungen zum
einen da eintritt eines konventionellen
krieges in europa zum anderen die
schnelle reaktionsfähigkeit der
westlichen welt und zum dritten
der widerstand der ukrainischen
bevölkerung
für alle jene und vor allem für den
ersten bereich die sich mit
strategischen forschung beschäftigen war
da teil 1 vorhersehbar und immer an ada
bei der erstellung eines risiko bildes
gehen wir von umfeld szenarien aus das
ist der startpunkt und das bedeutet dass
alle denkbaren möglichkeiten einmal
untersucht werden und damit sie sich
dahinter was vorstellen können das ist
so der zerfall der europäischen union
also wir haben keine einschränkung im
denken in einem ersten schritt das heißt
auf einem zeithorizont auf einem
zeitstrahl von 15 jahren denken wir
solche szenarien
der nächste schritt der nennt sich
drängt analyse das heißt wir versuchen
mit schlüsselfaktoren das zu verknüpfen
was heißt dass damit sie sich wieder
etwas vorstellen können dass sein macht
politik was sie sieht der großen mächte
in der welt es sind
wohlstandsverteilung es sind rohstoff
verteilung und englisch ist und daraus
können wir dann in einem ersten schritt
wahrscheinlichkeiten ableiten also wohin
geht der trend in etwa der dritte
schritt mit dem wir dieses risiko bilder
und die strategischen vorstellen ist
sozusagen daraus risiken zu heraus zu
destabilisieren und sozusagen
herausfordern und auch chancen die frau
bundesminister angesprochen auch chancen
um es wieder in eine positive richtung
lenken zu können
sollen dabei sozusagen
herauskristallisiert werden wieder als
beispiel
ein risiko könnte seine soziale
verwerfungen es könnte sein die
anfälligkeit einer gesellschaft für
populismus und ähnliches mehr
risiko bilder werden dann sitzen auf den
einzelnen ebenen so zogen ausgebreitet
also welche auswirkungen welche negative
auswirkungen auf österreich hat es oder
die europäische union das heißt ab
diesem zeitpunkt können wir
gegenmaßnahmen einleiten ja wesentlich
ist sozusagen auch hier weil das immer
langfristige dinge sind die richtigen
zeitpunkt zu finden ein weiterer
positiver schritt den wir daraus machen
können und ableiten können seien
handlungsoptionen handlungsoptionen zum
einen für die politik für die
militärische führungen für andere
ministerien aber natürlich auch für
gesellschaft oder für die gesellschaften
weil in zeiten der unsicherheit gibt es
so was ähnliches wie sehnsucht nach
optionen um die komplexität ein bisschen
zu vereinfachen damit sie sich auch hier
wieder etwas vorstellen können dass sein
zb
grundlagen für die ausrichtung des
österreichischen bundesheeres
streitkräfte profil wäre zb 112 punkte
das heißt ein risiko bild eine
strategische vorschau ist immer ein
ständiger kreislauf ja der
grundlage für planungen und empfehlungen
beinhaltet das heißt es ist auch wichtig
zu berücksichtigen dass das risikobild
keine tagespolitische information ist
sondern es ist etwas was mit fakten und
methoden versucht in die zukunft
bedrohungsanalysen zulegen und es ist
sehr wichtig und sie können sich
vorstellen dass wir jetzt bereits an den
aktuellen neuerungen die sich durch den
kleine konflikte um arbeiten und
vielleicht steht am ende dieses
prozesses ein begriff der lautet
eiserner vorhang 2.0 globale hybride
konflikte das könnte unter umständen
einzelne sein meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren für 20 22 wie gesagt
redaktionsschluss war im dezember werde
ich doch einige punkte noch heraus
greifen möchte aber vorher drei
grundlegenden dinge ansprechen zum einen
ein risiko bild ist immer so ein
bisschen zu sehen wenn sie sich das
bildlichen kopf vorstellen wie ein wie
ein getriebe ändert sich ein zahnrad
ändert sich die gesamte konstellation
das zweite ist heute schon angesprochen
worden verflechtungen ich nehme auch
andere begriffe vernetzung
globalisierung wäre zum beispiel so
etwas wir müssen uns unbedingt bewusst
sein dass das jetzt in dieser zeit die
globalisierung
immer im rucksack unsicherheit mit
transportiert das ist sozusagen ganz im
gegenteil wir sind oft sehr begeistert
von dem was die globalisierung zuletzt
auch für den persönlichen nutzen aber so
zum unsicherheit ist ein wesentlicher
bestandteil des ganzen drittens wir
müssen in wirkungsketten denken das
bedeutet dass dinge die in fernost
basieren auch auswirkungen auf
österreich haben werden und auch
katalysator wirkungen kein dritten
werden ich werde auf das doch noch ganz
kurz kommen greife jetzt vier große
blöcke heraus die wir hier abgebildet
und
ausgearbeitet haben zum einen die
militärische eskalation des konfliktes
ist eingetreten und neben den
militärischen konsequenzen die wir ja
ständig analysieren und ableiten und das
wo sie alle merken nehmen steigende
lebensmittelpreise
heizungskosten steigen an gibt es
natürlich ganz andere auswirkungen auch
die wir mit bedenken müssen ich greife
hier nur zwei heraus zum einen
wie sind die auswirkungen auf die
internationalen organisationen
beispiel mandat verlängern darf nur in
den raum stellen was was passiert wenn
es keine mandatsverlängerung am
westbalkan gibt die konsequenzen seien
für österreich sofort spüren das zweite
ist die einstufung des internationalen
rechts dass konfliktlösungsmechanismen
wenn das nicht mehr wahrgenommen wird
was bedeutet das für die zukunft
zweiter großer bereich die hybriden
bedrohungen meine damen und herren
werden wir alle in dem saal für mehrere
tage darüber nachdenken würden was
hybride bedrohungen seien und wie man
eine gesellschaft mit hybriden
bedrohungen angreifen kommt könnten
würden sich wahrscheinlich nur einen
bruchteil herausarbeiten können der
tatsächlich möglich und in diesem ganzen
computer hybriden bedrohungen gibt es
einen der ganz wesentlich ist nämlich
der der desinformation
desinformationskampagne
propaganda das herstellen von lethargie
gegenüber anderen alternativen
informationen und des unterstützt durch
cyber um zeit bei möglichkeiten die
bestehen der dritte große punkt die
migration
natürlich haben wir jetzt auch mit den
migrations bewegung
flüchtlingsbewegungen aus der ukraine zu
tun aber
wir haben aufgrund des u keine
konfliktes natürlich schon die ersten
auswirkungen der versorgung in afrika
den nahen osten und das wiederum kann zu
groß und problemen sein dass bereits
jetzt schwache staaten weiter
destabilisiert werden und vielleicht
kollabieren und daraus ergibt sich eine
nächste welle von migration den vierten
und letzten prächtigen sich kurz an
sprechen möchte ist der zusammengefasst
blättert man ii mi
klimakrise die wirken hier als
katalysator verstärken und es ist so wir
werden wahrscheinlich migrations
beschleunigungen und haben durch extreme
wetterereignisse in
unterschiedlichen regionen aber
natürlich auch österreich nicht
ausgeschlossen wir werden uns
auseinandersetzen müssen wasser
zusammenbruch von energieversorgung und
betrifft in der frage des blackouts zum
beispiel oder welche auswirkungen zb die
erfolgreiche oder nicht erfolgreiche
pandemie bekämpfung in den einzelnen
staaten mit sich bringt zwischen arm und
reich zum beispiel
zusammenfassend möchte ich vier punkte
an bringen mit einer bitte und
vielleicht mit einer positiven ausgang
zum einen die vernetzten gefahren können
meiner mutter nur mit einer vernetzten
abwehr bewältigt werden das heißt für
recht sprechen wir in zukunft von einer
multitalente fans polizei oder von einer
multi domain die fans
wesentlicher bestandteil von dem wirt
kooperation sein also es wird nicht ohne
kooperation gehen und nun zum ende
meiner ausführung meine damen und herren
würde ich das fast als eine bitte
formulieren
dass sie ihre bedrohungs wahrnehmung
nicht reduzieren die risiken bleiben
bestehen die wenigsten verschwinden von
selbst und wir haben jetzt mehrere
gleichzeitig weit verweise nur darauf in
der sahel zone am westbalkan überall
entwickeln sich sozusagen negative
trends und das könnte vielleicht zu
viele überraschungen führen und damit
wenn ich meine ausführungen dass wir
daraus die richtigen schlüsse ziehen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
herzlichen danke bringt ihr auch das
herausgreifen dieser punkte wir werden
jetzt fünf punkte aus dieser risiko
landschaft 20 22 besprechen mit
autorinnen die die risikoreichsten
punkte davon abgedeckt haben mich bitte
auf die bühne politische reihenfolge der
generalstabschef des österreichischen
bundesheeres ab 20 22 auch vorsitzender
des militärausschusses general robert
brigitte darf ist einfach hinnehmen mich
bitten
wenn bei uns die stellvertretende
direktorin des instituts für security
studies die sich nicht nur mit
konflikten im nahen osten und nordafrika
befasst sondern auch mit geopolitischen
verwerfungen und da steckt man mitten
drinnen florence gaub herzlich
willkommen in wien
[Applaus]
damit schnitt muss sich entschuldigen
aber ich freue mich sehr dass der
professor für politikwissenschaft der
sich genau mit unseren themen befasst an
der universität wien und auch an der
diplomatischen akademie bei uns ist
patrick müller dass sie zu uns retten
das sind in florence doppelten
es war schon angesprochen und wir haben
es auch alle zwei jahre lang miterlebt
das pandemie einer der grossen risiken
ist und mit ungewissen ausgang ich bitte
die stellvertreter tief mit vorsitzende
der gecko und generalsekretärin für
öffentliche gesundheit katharina reicht
zu uns auf die bühne
und schließlich vielleicht eines der
thema das die breite bevölkerung
mit am meisten beschäftigte frage was
ist wenn der strom ausfällt einer thema
jetzt tatsächlich besprechen muss man
kein gas hat und dazu haben wir den
blackout experten und den experten für
krisenvorsorge bei uns herbert herzlich
willkommen
ich würde das ganze organisieren dass
sie jeweils aus ihren bereichen aus
ihren forschungen und seinen kurzen im
pop geben so fünf bis zehn minuten und
wir das dann diskutieren in zwei drei
runden was bedeutet das für die aktuelle
situation mit diesem ukraine krieg und
was sind die schlussfolgerungen für ein
land wie österreich also für kleinere
länder wie kann man sich vorbereiten
vielleicht zum schluss auch noch was
bedeutet für die bevölkerung ich darf
sie bitten general zu beginnen es können
sich danach im mikro nehmen
das hörbar danke
sehr geehrte damen und herren die ich
bin ersucht worden über den aspekt
strategischer kompass und den einfluss
auf die ja so wichtig erkannte
strategische autonomie der europäischen
union zu sprechen und ich darf ihnen
dazu einige überlegungen vortragen
der strategische kompass ist eine
kombination aus konzept und
handlungsanweisung und insofern glaube
ich ein novum in der entwicklung der
gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
er soll ein beitrag zur globalen und
transatlantischen sicherheit sein in
ergänzung zum transatlantischen bündnis
und nicht in konkurrenz dazu
der zeitpunkt seiner verabschiedung
durch die zuständigen instanzen der
europäischen union könnte aktueller und
dramatischer nicht sein ist die ukraine
krise heute mehrfach angesprochen worden
und
man könnte von einem zeitpunkt sprechen
der das ende oder post normalität in
europa
kennzeichnet diese normalität nach dem
ende des kalten krieges hat nun
offensichtlich
keine aktualität mehr wir kennen die
europäische union als großes
friedensprojekt als erfolgreiches
friedensprojekt und globaler akteur aber
doch vorwiegend in wirtschaftlich
finanzieller und politischer hinsicht
solange es um soft power geht bei der
hard power hat
josé thorel kürzlich geäußert usdollar
language of power das heißt die
militärisch sicherheitspolitische
komponente ist nicht in einem umfang
ausgeprägt die geeignet wäre die
herausforderungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zu adressieren
um dieses westliche liberale welt
ordnungs modell nach dem ende des kalten
krieges ist in vieler hinsicht
herausgefordert das ist im risikobild
angesprochen worden
und ich möchte nun in aller kürze weil
nur zehn minuten zur verfügung stehen
die haupt pakete des strategischen
kompasses ihnen kurz vorstellen und
diese ansprechen ist sind mehrere
kapitel
es geht um die begriffe act also handeln
secure sichern invest
spricht für sich und partner die
zusammenarbeit die heute auch schon
mehrfach als so wichtig betont wurde im
zentrum des ersten paktes
steht die notwendigkeit dass die
europäische union auch unabhängig vom
transatlantischen bündnis und anderen
akteuren gemeinsam und rasch
handlungsfähig sein sollen in allen
domänen land- luft- see- cyberraum und
weltraum
zu diesem zweck wurde als verbesserung
und ergänzung und weiterentwicklung der
bekannten you battlegroups eine rapid
deployment guide city mit bis zu 5000
mann angedacht
hier geht es darum eine entry fonds zur
verfügung zu haben die in allen domänen
handlungsfähig ist und die eine erste
militärische reaktion auf eintretende
krisen sicherstellen kann
wie diese
entry fonds diese treppe traction fonds
nun zu sehen ist im zusammenhang mit dem
alten headline goldziel eine eu
streitmacht von 60.000 mann aufzustellen
wird eine politische und
sicherheitspolitische aufgabe der
zukunft sein dass aus zu definieren weil
schon die größenordnung und der umfang
einer derartigen
streitkräfte konzeption legt nahe dass
es sich nur um eine erste an und handeln
kann
dessen ungeachtet sind gerade im
zusammenhang mit dem ersten korb
sehr konkrete schritte vorgesehen schon
2023 soll eine erste gemeinsame übung
einer derartigen entry force stattfinden
und davor sind die europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten gehalten das
sicherheits und krisen bild das wir
gerade so lebhaft vorgetragenen erhalten
haben noch einmal eine revision und
aktualisierung zu unterziehen das heißt
so wie hier in österreich ein risiko
bild erstellt wird geschieht das auch
auf ebene der europäischen union und
dieses risiko bild wird im laufe des
heurigen jahres entsprechend erweitert
und aktualisiert werden
es geht auch darum hier eine
entsprechende kommandostruktur
einzuziehen
die military training war kontakt
capability die also diese kommando
funktion die aus politischen gründen
bislang so nicht reißen darf innehat
wird ab 2025 alle nicht exekutiven aber
auch kleinere und mittlere exekutive
maßnahmen und kooperationen zu leiten
haben
ich erinnere daran dass die
notwendigkeit von kommandostrukturen in
der europäischen union zu etablieren ein
thema lebhafter politische
konsultationen in der vergangenheit war
und dass ich aber im lichte der jüngsten
entwicklungen sehr wohl die
notwendigkeit
bestätigt hat und zwar dramatischer als
wir das vielleicht wünschen ich darf zum
zweiten paket kommen das ist das paket
secure sicherheit hier geht es um die
steigerung der resilienz es soll eine
sogenannte hybrid toolbox etabliert
werden die die koordinierte reaktion auf
hybride angriffe entwicklungen eines
einheitlichen analyseverfahrens
beinhaltet
es soll die eu weltraum strategie
aktualisiert werden und auch die
erfassung
maritimer sicherheitslage und
situationen
künftig in einem verbesserten verfahren
ermöglicht werden dazu kommt ein
vaterland klimawandel und verteidigung
es ist heute schon angeklungen auch die
thematik einer
klimafreundlichen und grimmen
klimaneutralen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik bis hin auf die
technischen auswirkungen bei der
ausgestaltung der streitkräfte ist thema
in der europäischen union und ist ebenso
wie in der nato eine zu verfolgende
zielsetzung
der dritte bereich
investitionen beinhaltet mehr und
zielgerichtete investitionen mit dem
ziel agile mobile
interoperable technologisch
fortschrittliche
energieeffiziente und residente
streitkräfte zu entwickeln
ich bitte um verständnis für diese
wort ansammlung aber es ist der versuch
in einem kompakten papier kompakte
zielsetzungen sozusagen
auszudrücken und und verständlich zu
machen
dazu wird es einen defence innovation
hub im rahmen der europäischen
verteidigungsagentur geben und es wird
das schwergewicht bei den investitionen
auf den sogenannten strategic and
numbers liegen es gibt hier wesentlichen
nachholbedarf etwa im bereich der marine
streitkräfte kampfflugzeuge
aufklärungssatelliten aber auch
mechanisierte streitkräfte um nur wenige
zu männern
insgesamt hat hier die europäische union
das ziel gesetzt
gemeinsame budgetmittel auch vermehrt
verteidigungspolitischen zielsetzungen
nutzbar zu machen und für alle
mitgliedsstaaten die motivation
ausgesetzt ihre budgets entsprechend zu
erhöhen und anzupassen
der dritte
bereich
patron der vierte bereich partnerschaft
kann man arbeit ist heute auch schon
mehrfach adressiert worden hier wird es
darum gehen die bemühungen der
europäischen union auf bilateraler aber
auch multilateraler ebene zu
intensivieren hier geht es um eine klare
definition der aufgabenteilung mit dem
atlantischen bündnis ich habe schon
gesagt eu auch robuste missionen kleiner
und mittlerer größenordnung das thema
der kollektiven verteidigung wird auf
sicht natürlich in den händen der nato
bleiben es geht weiter darum auch mit
staaten außerhalb der europäischen union
wie den vereinigten staaten
großbritannien kanada und norwegen
lebhafte und und zukunfts robuste
partnerschaften zu etablieren auf den
verschiedenen handlungsfeldern aber auch
die zivil militärische zusammenarbeit zu
intensivieren
nun wenn man also diese vier pakete fast
dann komme ich nochmal zurück auf das
eingangsstatement dass das strategische
kompass eigentlich eine mischung ist
zwischen einem konzept und eine
handlungsanweisung die sehr ambitioniert
und auch zeitlich
entsprechend terminisiert ist mit klar
zu erreichenden zielsetzungen zum
beispiel die raschen reaktions kräfte
bis 2025 einsatzbereit zu machen
diese mischung aus konzept even und
konkreten aspekten ist auch in der
militär publizistik durchaus kritisch
aufgenommen worden ich glaube aber das
ist der legitime versuch ist diese
erkannte notwendigkeit europa auch
militärisch sicherheitspolitisch
handlungsfähig zu machen tatsächlich
umzusetzen
und damit der sehr geehrte damen und
herren bin ich auch schon beim einer
zusammenfassung die frage ist nachgerade
wie kann europa seine rolle in einer
sich entwickelnden
konfrontativen geopolitischen situation
behaupten
wie können solidarität und beschleunigte
entscheidungs modelle gefördert werden
wie kann der zugang europas zum globalen
gemeingütern wie den seewegen
sauber und weltraum gesichert werden wie
kann letztlich die resilienz der union
gegen strategische schock ereignisse
verbessert werden
meine antwort
habe ich ihn in drei kurzen punkten
zusammen zu fassen versucht
wir haben sehr oft der die europäische
union als eine union der
ankündigungspolitik erlebt und es wird
hier darum gehen ankündigungspolitik in
aktives handeln
überzuleiten
die angeführten fragen können also
letztlich in jenen maßnahmen ihre
realisierung finden die in den
angeführten körben des
strategischen kompasses zusammengefasst
sind
die svp wird im rahmen der institutionen
der europäischen union ein erhöhtes
gewicht beizumessen seien letztlich und
das ist das entscheidende sehr geehrte
damen und herren es geht nur mit dem
politischen willen das 27 der politische
wille hierfür muss entwickelt werden und
zwar auch unter inkaufnahme gewisser
einschränkungen der souveränität der
mitgliedsstaaten nur so wird eine
nachhaltige verbesserung der
resilienz der europäischen union und
ihrer fähigkeit auf militärische
bedrohungen auch militärisch zu
antworten erreichbar sein vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
hat sich ein danke general für diesen
exzellenten einstieg in die diskussion
ich möchte dass zunächst an sie beide
aus der wissenschaft weiter geben das
ist ja etwas das lange aus notwendig
erkannt wurden schon lange angekündigt
war aber jetzt in der realität über zu
gehen scheint diesmal so generali fragt
sie dann noch welche rolle sie spielen
werden ich möchte auf der geopolitischen
ebene und dann auf der europäischen
besprechen zuerst mit ihnen frau grott
würde ich sie bitten um ihren input was
das an geopolitischen verschiebungen zu
grunde hat und was es dann bedeutet in
weiterer folge und natürlich in der
jetzigen situation besonders bitte
verbaut danke
ich weiß nicht ob sie viele hier im raum
kennen wahrscheinlich das buch von
lorenz friedman der future
history der zweite teil des titels wird
gerne vergessen es ist nicht so sehr ein
buch in der es um die zukunft unseres
krieges geht sondern wie in der
vergangenheit menschen den krieg
erwartet haben und die die
schlussfolgerungen dieses dieses sehr
interessanten buchs es geht zurück bis
ins 19 jahrhundert ist der krieg so wie
man ihn erwartet findet fast nie statt
also es passiert immer was anderes als
dass man das erwartet hat und das ist
jetzt auch gerade aktuell der fall wenn
sie mental zurückgehen in den januar 20
22 oder auch davor dann wissen sie dass
das wir alle erwartet haben dass alle
gedacht haben der konflikt der zukunft
das ist alles bis zur hemmschwelle pure
gewalt die sogenannten connectivity wars
oder hybride kriegsführung oder der
websession of everything also die
tatsache dass man alles zu einer waffe
macht was per se keine waffe ist also
flüchtlinge
computernetzwerke
wirtschaft information etc
und bisher also was ich bisher besonders
spannend finde ist dass die ukraine und
zeigt dass nichts davon ist so
eingetreten also wir haben eher den
krieg beschrieben sowie er war oder
extrapoliert und gedacht so geht es dann
immer weiter aber wir haben bisher in
der ukraine nicht besonderen großem
einsatz von cyber gesehen das kann sich
natürlich noch ändern aber bisher schon
mal nicht auch gegen europäische ziele
hat nicht besonders viel mehr cyber
attacks gegeben wir haben vorhin gehört
es ist natürlich schon auf dem hohen
niveau also in europa findet jede jede
woche werden mindestens drei staatliche
oder oder staatsnahe institutionen
angegriffen mit cyber attacks dreimal
bronze das ist schon das ist schon
ziemlich stark aber jetzt seit der
ukraine ist es auf dem niveau geblieben
mit einer ausnahme die ihre die rumänen
sind einmal stark angegriffen waren also
die cyber dimension bisher nicht so
eingetreten flüchtlinge
bis vor paar wochen dachten wir noch
flüchtlinge ist das schlimmste was uns
passieren kann weil es uns zerreißt
politisch jetzt haben wir einen
flüchtling situation die die syrer in
den schatten stellt polen alleine hat
doppelt so viele flüchtlinge aufgenommen
ukrainische flüchtlinge als deutschland
damals syrer aufgenommen hat zweieinhalb
millionen dahinter rumänien über eine
halbe million ungarn und moldawien kurz
darunter ungarn ungarn was noch von
einem jahr ich glaube ich hab mir die
tagesschau 50 asylanträge pro jahr hatte
und davon und dann ziehen durchgegangen
also das ist schon das ist schon
interessant wie viel sich da verschoben
hat und wie viel anders gekommen ist als
wir gedacht haben die haben gedacht eine
flüchtlings krise wird uns zerreißen
sanktionen
bis foto greiner war das die einzige
waffe die
europa eingesetzt hat das haben wir
natürlich jetzt wieder gemacht aber es
ist bei weitem nicht das einzige ist es
eigentlich ja in der ganzen liste von
waffenlieferungen und vor allem von der
rhetorik ist es ja eine eine von einer
eine wichtige waffe aber nicht mehr die
einzige und dann das informationen also
wenn ihnen mal fahrt ist gehen sie auf
twitter und folgen sie den russischen
außenministerium wenn wir bis januar
gedacht haben die russen können
wahnsinnig gutes informieren die machen
das so wahnsinnig toll dann lade ich sie
dazu eigentlich diesen twitter-feed
anzuschauen das ist fast ironisch aus
also sie machen das alles aber nicht
elegant
was heißt es also krieg ist nicht ist
nie das was wir erwartet haben
das heißt aber nicht dass ich damit
auseinandersetzen im vorfeld falsch ist
und die ministerin hat es ja vorher
schon angekündigt was ich toll finde in
österreich ist eines der länder das sich
schon viele gedanken macht im vorfeld
ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin in vielen
anderen europäischen staaten da ist es
nicht so der fall ich denke jetzt gerade
an deutschland zum beispiel
je weniger man sich im vorfeld also mit
auseinandersetzt desto größer ist die
fallhöhe die strategische community in
deutschland wie gesagt dass zum beispiel
aktuell würde ich sagen immer noch im
schockzustand
nicht weil die informationen nicht da
waren sondern weil man es nicht glauben
wollen und das ist jetzt für mich
eigentlich die interessantere frage und
dann komme ich auch auf ihre frage was
heißt das jetzt alles für die zukunft
also erstens die unmittelbare zukunft
wie geht es jetzt weiter aus der
wissenschaft kann ich ihnen sagen und
sie die meisten im raum haben uniform an
sie wissen dass sowieso einen krieg
zwischen staaten geht normal sind nicht
schnell zu ende dass das tut jetzt einem
europäer meistens wie so was zu hören
denn je länger ein krieg dauert desto
mehr opfer wird es geben aber im
durchschnitt dauert ein
zwischenstaatlicher krieg 15 monate okay
natürlich da gibt es variationen
wesentlich länger wesentlich kürzer aber
sie wissen auch alle hier dass der
blitzkrieg ein sehr seltenes phänomen
ist sechs tage krieg israel zum beispiel
falklandkrieg aber grundsätzlich
brauchen kriege zeit und zeit ist eine
ressource die wir aktuell im westen
nicht mehr haben wir denken alles muss
immer sofort passieren der install krieg
deswegen finde ich interessant sie
denken hier natürlich auch viel über
überm ätherisches equipment nach ich bin
ich kümmere mich eher um die software
was passiert in den köpfen wie haben wir
die mentale richtige einstellung wie
können wir flexibel reagieren also das
erste ist zeit wir müssen der sache zeit
lassen je schneller man einen krieg
vorzubereiten
desto weniger löst man ihn auf sondern
manchmal fries ist ihnen denn sie wissen
alle dass wir konflikt überall auf der
welt haben die ich meines konflikt erben
die einfach die nachfahren von
ungelösten konflikten sind die ukraine
selber ist der nachfahre eines
ungelösten konflikts von 20 14 und davor
im nahen osten die region die ich
besonders gut kenne wimmelt es von
konflikt erben ein konflikt muss
aufgelöst werden nicht nur beendet wenn
ich glaube das haben wir europäer falsch
verstanden das ist nicht unbedingt das
gleiche ist das heißt für mich
mindestens bis zum sommer wird es in der
ukraine noch dauern
wunschdenken war vorhin schon wurde von
schon angesprochen jedes mal wenn die
russische regierung irgendwas sagt was
in unsere richtung geht's erinnern sich
letzte woche wurde angekündigt okay wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt nur noch auf die
ost ukraine um ich zitiere vertrauen
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen in die
verhandlungen wir haben die bilder
gesehen seitdem also können davon
ausgehen dass man nicht glauben kann was
nicht auch und nachweisbar ist da ist
unser wunschdenken alt dann in diese
richtung wir wollen natürlich dass es so
ist fakt ist aber das was was andere
gerade passiert also das ist das erste
die unmittelbare zukunft das wird noch
länger dauern das zweite ist aber das
geopolitische und da ist
glaube ich ist diese herausforderungen
jetzt das was sie die die überlegungen
die sie hier haben im bundesheer im
verteidigungsministerium hinauszutragen
in die österreichische gesellschaft denn
es reicht nicht mehr das muss sich
gedanken machen darüber wie es draußen
weitergehen werden gerade schon über das
gas gesprochen es ist alles jetzt teil
der gesamtbevölkerung es ist jede jede
betroffen und jede jeder muss verstehen
dass solche solche sachen können einfach
passieren der punkt ist nicht dass wir
wollen jetzt nicht alle nur angst machen
sondern wir wollen uns darauf
vorbereiten und vor sei das problem bei
vorzeit finde ich oft ist ich mache ja
viel vor sagt zukunft voraus wir meinen
kollegen haben so eine tendenz zeigen
aber alles auf was schiefgehen kann aber
das reicht ja nicht also man muss auch
sagen was können wir jetzt tun denn
foresight action das bringt nichts also
es bringt mir nichts wenn ich ihnen eine
vorband machen wir müssen darüber
nachdenken wie gehen wir damit um 10
finde ich auch die debatte über den
ukraine krieg interessant weil ich denke
ok selbst wenn sie es ernst genommen
hätten selbst wenn sie gedacht hätten
sogar beiden haben wir ja nicht ernst
genommen weil es ja gesagt habe ich
glaub dir osten greifen an stelle des
ernst genommen was hätten wir dann
gemacht hätten wir dann truppen in die
ukraine verlegt oder an die grenze oder
hätten wir schon mal angefangen mit
waffenlieferung also ich glaube man muss
auch verstehen dass selbst erkannt
hätten weiß ich nicht was wir
tatsächlich hätten tun können oder was
wir
willens wären gewesen zu tun denn unsere
strategische kultur war nicht da gibt
schon so einen gewissen fatalismus man
hätte gar nicht mental aus dieser
denkhaltung rauskommen könnte und da
sind wir dabei raus aus der denkhaltung
und dann schauen wir mal noch weiter
nach vorne über den sommer 2022 hinaus
wir wissen dass es für russland nicht
nur um die ukraine gehen es geht für die
für russland geht es um die langfristige
zukunft für die chinesen übrigens auch
die chinesen schreiben ist ganz
interessant finde ich übrigens dass wir
den anderen ganz oft gar nicht zu hören
also wenn die leute sagen es hat ja
keiner kommen gesehen dann meinen wir
immer nur ich habe es nicht kommen
gesehen und warum nicht weil ich habe
mir noch nicht mal angeschaut was die
anderen sagen die russen schreiben ganz
klar in ihren vorzeit papieren ich
zitiere die zukunft ist zurück das ende
der geschichte von fukuyama das ist
vorbei die zukunft ist auch für uns
wieder zu gestalten nachdem der westen
sie die ganze zeit gestellt hat und wir
wollen sie jetzt gestalten wir wollen
dass bis 2030 eine neue weltordnung
entsteht ich zitiere das alles können
sie auf dem wallberg klub website
herunterladen
auch spannend ist übrigens das in
russischer science fiction sind schon
seit den 90er jahren das thema eines
kriegs in der ukraine
der russland dem mit dem russland und
der westen in der ukraine flaschen ist
seit den neunzigerjahren russischen
science fiction ganz prominent ist und
ständiges thema also für alles sei fans
im raum bitte weiterlesen science
fiction das durchaus auch eine wichtige
quelle das heißt also selbst wenn wir
den krieg in russland in der ukraine
schnell beenden dann ändern wir aber
nicht das langfristige und ich glaube du
ein bisschen aufwachen und erkennen dass
diese die welt von davor ist weg das
heißt aber nicht dass wir hoffnungslosen
sind das heißt auch nicht dass wir uns
dem so einfach gibt fügen müssen sondern
wir müssen die ärmel hochkrempeln
erkennen dass wir resilient da sind wir
kommen jetzt gleich zur pandemie das
haben wir gott sei dank in der pandemie
trat schon gelernt und dass wir etwas
tun können herzlichen dank frau danke
sagen
dann würde ich bevor wir zu den
konkreten österreichischen dem pandemie
und blackout kommen auf die europäische
ebene kommen mit ihnen herr müller
welche rolle sieht europa für sich da
drinnen und was ist möglich
herr general hat er gesagt also es wird
daran gearbeitet aber es müssen jetzt
alle 27 länder das sagen wollen und das
ist verbunden damit dass man die eigene
souveränität zu einem gewissen grad auch
einschränkt die bereitschaft muss da
sein was ist denn er assessment der lage
der geopolitischen position europas in
dieser situation
vielen dank und
liebe damen und herren albert einstein
hat einmal gesagt dass er sich besonders
für die zukunft interessiert weil dort
gedenkt er zu leben also die zukunft
interessiert im märz die vergangenheit
aber er hat auch gesagt dass die
vergangenheit wichtig ist um die zukunft
einzuschätzen und zu verstehen und um
europa zu thematisieren würde ich gerne
ein paar punkte erst ansprechen wie
europa über die welt nachgedacht hat und
was jetzt wichtige geopolitische trend
sind um das ein bisschen
gegenüberzustellen und ich glaube nicht
dass sehr viele einschätzungen die schon
gekommen sind aber ich glaube nicht dass
die welt von gestern verschwunden ist
der viele dynamiken sind weiter da und
überlappen sich jetzt ja und das ist
ganz zentral wie haben wir denn den
globalen kontext in europa eingeschätzt
und wie hat er sich dann entwickelt also
eine ganz zentrale annahme war eine
interdependenz die welt ist eigentlich
gut und vorteilhaft für europa für
andere staaten auch also
wirtschaftsbeziehungen die
digitalisierung technisierung
internationale lieferketten eine globale
wirtschaft das fördert wachstum das
schafft austausch in europa haben wir so
konflikte überwunden wir haben mit kohle
und stahl angefangen und über eine
vernetzung gemeinsame interessen tragen
wir konflikte nicht mehr gewaltsam
untereinander aus sondern über
verrechtlichung über
supranationale institutionen ja und das
gab dann so gedanken wie es ist die
wirtschaft und dies geht denn den
internationalen beziehungen nicht so
sehr die geopolitik bis hin zu fragen
wie es denn die zukunftsfähigkeit der
nato als verteidigungsbündnis
die zweite große annahme war system
gegensätze werden zunehmend verschwinden
als über eine einbindung chinas über
wirtschaftlichen austausch kommt es dort
zu einer transformation und wir haben ja
schon über fukuyama gehört na also
dieses ende der geschichte diese
konvergenz richtung liberale
marktwirtschaft
eine eine andere wichtige annahme die
dritte annahme war dass multilaterale
institutionen und die uno und die
weltbank et cetera und auch ein us eu
gestütztes internationales system ganz
wichtig sind für die internationalen
beziehungen
globale güter werden hergestellt
wir kooperieren friedlich miteinander
und natürlich wir können auch
grenzüberschreitende probleme die
nationale souveränität grenzen sprengen
angehen wie etwa die klimakrise
vierte große annahme war dass unsere
welt verschiedene akteure hat die
wichtig sind
andrews globale unternehmen und so
weiter mit einer relativ ruhigen brille
dass das alles irgendwie über einbindung
und kooperation und global governance
auch vorteilhaft ist und dann was jetzt
sehr stark auf die eu bezogen ist und
sie können das alles nachlesen was ich
sage und sie kennen das sicher ohnedies
europäische sicherheitsstrategie von
2003 da finden sie das alles abgebildet
und aus eu seite hat man gedacht man ist
ein modell für globales regierender man
man man ist auch multilateral bahn hat
auch institutionen mann hat recht über
nationalstaaten und man ist auch ein
transformationsprozess
für die nachbarschaft wir tragen unsere
werte unsere politiken in die nacht wird
nachbarschaft das ist keine reine
altruistische mission gewesen natürlich
wollen wir in einer stabilen
nachbarschaft leben und wir können diese
transformation schaffen ja über
erweiterungspolitik über
nachbarschaftspolitik können wir das
leisten ja und jetzt können wir das x
abgleichen mit wo wir uns jetzt befinden
also 2022 so so etwa zwei jahrzehnte
später als die globale
sicherheitsstrategie und was sehen wir
sehen dass spannungen zwischen
großmächten zu nehmen chinas beziehungen
zum westen sind angespannt und die
ukraine müssten wir jetzt gar nicht
treten und russland sehr aggressives
auftreten mit dem einsatz militärischer
mittel nicht rein nicht militärischer
mittel ganz wichtig was sind jetzt
unsere erwartungen jetzt unsere
erwartungen geopolitik ist zurück wir
müssen interdependenz vielmehr
sicherheitspolitisch denken diese
debatten reichen von resilienz bis hin
zu roger köppel inc eine debatte die
auch in den usa stark ist und und es hat
wieder all diese dimensionen ja also das
gibt über digitale die kapelle
die kapelle auch wirtschaft also
das sind das ein wichtiger debatten die
auch auf einen zukommen ja der zweite
trend den wir sehen ist nein die system
gegensätze lösen sich nicht auf ein
wandel durch handel wenn wir jetzt china
als beispiel nehmen hat insofern
stattgefunden als dass china
wirtschaftlich wächst dass es theo
technologisch stärker wird dass es auch
im militärischen bereich viel stärker
wird aber es wird nicht viel
demokratischer ja und ich muss jetzt
nicht von der arabischen welt reden ich
muss jetzt nicht darüber zu sehen dass
demokratie
rückläufig ist global was sich aber sehr
stark ansprechen möchte ist dass wir
auch gesehen haben dass liberale
demokratien sehr verletzlich sind ja
oder durchaus verletzlich wir müssen
nicht jetzt nur zurückdenken an was in
ungarn passiert das letzten sonntag
sondern wir müssen uns überlegen dass es
eine polarisierung gibt bis hin in die
usa und hätte ein ukraine krieg einige
jahre früher stattgefunden hätte und
einer präsidentschaft trump
stattgefunden wie wir uns da führen
würden möchte ich jetzt gar nicht näher
erläutern
internationale institutionen und
liberale weltordnung geraten zunehmend
unter druck aber natürlich bestehen
globale herausforderungen weiter eine
sehr starke vernetzung
passiert weiter und all das muss man
gemeinsam denken also wie man diese
institutionen reformiert wie effizient
und auch wie elastisch sie sind ja das
sind ganz zentrale fragen die uns auch
in der forschung beschäftigen hybride
und nichtstaatliche akteure werden zu
einer herausforderung für internationale
sicherheit nicht nur jetzt bewaffnete
gruppen und diese literatur die man ja
auch schon sehr lange hat sondern es
geht auch darum was bedeutet eigentlich
eine digitalisierung große
große firmen in diesem bereich wie muss
man die regulieren er wie geht man damit
um weil sie einen sehr sehr großen
impact haben auf unsere sicherheit ja
und als letzten trend als glaube ich den
man sehr deutlich sieht ist dass diese
soft power modells eu als ein modell
globalen regieren und transformations-
modell eigentlich nicht mehr trägt ja
das heißt man muss sich überlegen da
sind ja nicht nur sachen wie macht man
politik sondern auch dinge wie versteht
und definiert sich europa was ist unsere
identität und rolle im internationalen
system und auch damit darüber muss man
nachdenken und ich glaube was besonders
wichtig ist hier ist dass wir uns vor
augen führen dass die eu ein wichtiger
außenpolitischer akteur ist aber ein
sehr offenes ein sehr heterogenes system
und das schafft große möglichkeiten auch
für externen einfluss in der
außenpolitik treffen wir gemeinsame
entscheidungen einstimmig ja was
bedeutet es wenn wir zwei länder unter
artikel sieben verfahren haben in der
europäischen union und viele die
entwicklungen die wir vor augen haben ja
also da geht es auch wieder um rest
alliance da geht es aber auch um
integration um vernetzte sicherheit und
dass man zusammenhängt und dass auch ein
land wie österreich seine verantwortung
erkennt in einer vernetzten welt und
diese auch wahrnimmt und da glaube ich
gibt es auch einiges zu tun und freue
mich da auch auf die diskussion da
geschieht herzlichen danke danke
da würde ich gern mit ihnen beiden zu
zwei themen kommen die sehr sehr sehr
unmittelbar in österreich als risiko
gesehen werden und erlebt werden auch
schon vor diesen krieg die pandemie ist
jetzt schon mehrere male genannt worden
frau reich als etwas das uns resilienz
gebracht hat dass uns gezeigt dass in
russland besteht noch nicht so schlecht
da wie impfungen wir haben eine
impfpflicht diese anschalten können wenn
sie wollen
aber was ist dann ihr blick jetzt über
den sommer hinaus im sommer rechnen wir
damit dass wird besser und was ist der
blick darüber hinaus wie groß ist das
risiko noch im herbst winter nächstes
jahr und darüber hinaus
tatsächlich ist das wahrscheinlich das
schwierigste an der pandemie dass wir
immer wieder vor den gleichen
herausforderungen stehen nämlich dass
wir wissen dass wir nichts wissen
das problem ist ein bisschen dass wir
einen sehr schnellen veränderungs modus
haben dieser veränderungs modus
überfordert schon die wissen geschweige
denn alle anderen die sich mit dem thema
virologie bande mir vielleicht
inhaltlich einfach nicht so beschäftigen
können oder wollen und das ist ein das
ist das thema wo wir einerseits die
leeren unserer pandemie daraus team
gleichzeitig aber wissen wir werden die
dinge immer dann besprechen am planen
und vielleicht auch schon verpflichten
müssen wenn sie vielleicht noch gar
nicht so dringend sind das thema des
herbstes wird uns nicht im herbst
beschäftigen sondern es wird uns leider
im sommer beschäftigen und im sommer
wird es tatsächlich wahrscheinlich
niemanden interessieren das wissen wir
auch alle weil im sommer wollen wir alle
eigentlich sind nur urlaub machen wollen
weit weg reisen wollen verwandte
besuchen teilweise sind ja leute den
ganzen sommer auch weg deswegen es wird
uns genau in dieser zeit treffen die
entscheidungen
zu treffen und unsere verpflichtungen
sozusagen aufrecht aufrecht oder
wieder aufzustellen wenn gerade das
interesse am boden ist ich habe einfach
folien mitgebracht ich werde ihn endlich
habe ich heute nicht viel neues erzählen
weil wir alle diese pandemie nahezu als
spezialisten miterleben ich glaube wir
haben noch nie erlebt dass wir auf am
stammtisch in den kleinsten gasthäusern
über cd werte diskutieren über labor
chemische methoden über inkubationszeit
'nen unter quarantäne zeiten das sind
dinge die haben uns überrollt
tatsächlich wie eine wie eine dampfwalze
und es ist uns einfach auch nichts
anderes über geblieben sonst mit diesen
themen auseinanderzusetzen
allerdings oft nur mit einem leider
gefährlichem halbwissen
das wissen wir alle und aus diesem
leider gefährlichem halbwissen
haben wir mit gepaart mit unseren
eigenen erfahrungen zimmert sich
natürlich jeder sein bild und das ist
auch richtig und normal so die frage ist
schaffen wir es trotzdem ein
gesamtstaatliches bild zu bekommen und
ich möchte jetzt ganz kurz und schnell
die brücke zum bundesheer schlagen weil
meine meine meine dankbarkeit hier auf
diesem podium blickt dem bundesheer und
ich wünschte ich hätte rote striemen ja
schon ein paar monate früher an meiner
seite gewusst weil ich zwar prinzipiell
sehr verwöhnt bin dass das bundesheer
schon aber impfen sehr geholfen hat auch
jetzt bei den medikamenten mit herrn
generalmajor bernsteiner mit herrn
general ag hat mit absoluten top
spezialisten was die logistik betrifft
an meiner seite ist aber so richtig rund
ist mit dir geworden rudi deswegen mein
dank an dich warum weil uns von seiten
des gesundheitsministeriums natürlich
diese gesamtstaatliche aspekt was
könnten da alles noch dazu erst mit dem
bundesheer so wirklich leichter leichter
fällt und deswegen glaube ich ist eine
meiner meiner persönlichen lehren aus
den aus den letzten zwei jahren sich
wesentlich früher zu vernetzen mit
alldem jenen institutionen die auch
gesamtstaatlich agieren können wir sind
ein land des föderalismus das ist etwas
was uns ausmacht das ist auch österreich
aber dieser föderalismus oder nicht
unbedingt immer alles erleichtert
manches hat uns auch einfach erschwert
das hat keiner absichtlich geplant oder
getan sondern das liegt in der natur der
sache dass einfach in neun bundesländern
recht unterschiedliche ja sozialisierung
'nen auch haben und meine persönliche
lehre ist viel früher diesen
gesamtstaatlichen verbindenden aspekt zu
suchen und zu finden weil die
bundesländer gar nicht einmal selber
machen wollen es bleibt dann habe ich
mal einfach gar nichts anders über und
aus diesem aus dieser situation heraus
glaube ich könnten wir besser werden ich
habe ein paar dinge mitgebracht nicht
alle wie ich auch immer das schaffen
werde weil sich nicht an mental ja wie
wir die wir auch nicht alle durch
genießen aber sind sie ein paar ein paar
im putz mit dem heutigen tag haben wir
fast vier millionen bestätigte krone
fälle seit anbeginn der pandemie gehabt
also vier millionen das sind schon das
ist schon die hälfte muss man sagen und
das ist eigentlich in einer nie
dagewesenen dimension
tatsächlich eine eine besonderheit die
das gesundheitssystem nicht nur während
der pandemie vor herausforderungen
gestellt hat noch stellt sondern auch
intern nachwirkungen in der vielleicht
nach pandemischen zeit weiterhin vor
eine herausforderung stellt bei 4
millionen erkrankten sei es jetzt mehr
symptomatischer oder weniger
symptomatische können wir uns alle
ausmalen welche folge erkrankungen
daraus entstehen welche erkrankungen
wird durch diese pandemie nicht in
dieser art und weise angehen konnten wie
es eigentlich gewesen wäre wieviel unter
dieser virus decke sage ich jetzt doch
noch liegt was wir noch gar nicht zu
wissen deswegen ist es eine problematik
die und sicher nach der pandemie und
während der pandemie tatsächlich schon
vor herausforderungen stehen
man muss sagen
gelegen dazu in der band immer
zurückzuschauen sagen ja was ist
schlecht gelaufen was sie nun unsere
lehren de facto haben wir gezeigt was
wir können die sache mit dem spaß ist
uns wesentlich schneller gelungen als
eigentlich geplant gehabt hätten
deswegen ist so meine lehre wir können
es ja wenn man weint
manchmal
dummheit der lange überlegen und planen
und thun und schauen und machen und
kommen vor lauter überlegungen oft
weniger ins tun und die pandemie hat uns
glaube ich ein gezeigt wir kennen wenn
man wollen auch ganz schnell und diesen
spirit sollten uns ein bisschen erhalten
in meiner wahrnehmung weil manchmal
braucht man den speed speed kills heißt
immer aber in dem fall nein manche dinge
können am boden und dann entwickelt wenn
sie da sind die werden nicht besser wenn
wir sie länger kochen und deswegen ist
das thema das ihm spaß ist eigentlich
eine erfolgsgeschichte war lang genug
geplant und viele länder beneiden uns um
den ehemals wir können damit ganz schön
viele steckt großes potenzial dahinter
die individualisierte und
beratungen sind möglich wir können das
auswerten und zwar natürlich
datenschutzkonform aber wir können
endlich auswerten wie unsere umfrage im
land ist und dazu muss man sagen es wird
doch vielleicht ein bisschen dazu
beitragen dass wir diese wissenschafts
fertigkeit dieser ein bisschen jetzt
auch hoch geworden ist und im rahmen von
verschwörungstheorien reichs bürgern und
sonstigen gruppierungen
hier recht recht schwierig geworden ist
diese wissenschafts feindlichkeit ein
bisschen bekämpfen weil wir einfach
besser bescheid wissen mit daten
transparenter arbeiten können wir haben
auch jetzt natürlich durch den ukrainer
konflikt auch den durch den krieg kommen
die bedrohungen die abseits der pandemie
uns wieder dieses thema der der
der imf compliance in unserem land
natürlich zeigen weil das alles
vielleicht in österreich und immer
wieder ein kleines problem aber in
anderen ländern ist tatsächlich viel
mehr es ist das thema polio
kinderlähmung krankheiten die eigentlich
unsere bevölkerung kaum noch betreffen
so weit gar nicht weg und es wird sich
es wird nicht ganz gut sein wenn wir in
unserem land mit dem mit dem impfen
nicht wieder einen größeren einen
direkteren abrutschen direkteren zugang
zur bevölkerung bekommen weil die
bedrohung einfach nicht so weit
außerhalb unseres landes liegt
die dokumentation von
entscheidungsprozessen das ist etwas was
natürlich sehr jetzt im licht der
öffentlichkeit auch diskutiert wird
viele dinge die anderen für sich in
kleinen gremien im wissenschaftszug
spezialisten kreisen lange diskutiert
werden kontrovers diskutiert werden
bisher dann am schluss eine lösung
herauskommt werden wir uns im lichte der
öffentlichkeit diskutiert und zwar auf
der grünen zeitungsseite 2 in allen
medien in jedem auf jeden auf jeden
stammtisch und das macht es nicht gerade
leicht ich beschwere mich nicht darüber
aber es ist einfach eine völlig neue
dimension
die einen normalen wissenschaftlichen
diskurs den wir eigentlich führender der
em kontroverse ist sogleich im
transparenten liegt dieser
öffentlichkeit führen das ist etwas was
menschen belastet und überfordert weil
es einfach nicht gewöhnt ist damit
umzugehen
was wir versuchen ist natürlich auch
kommissionen nicht mehr selber darf zwei
kommissionen vorsitzenden eine eine
gemeinsam mit dir machen wurde
das thema der krone kommission es gibt
fachgremien es gibt noch fachausschüsse
wir haben ganz schön viel in diesem
lande zusammengesammelt im laufe der
pandemie jede kommissionen den zweck das
auch nicht ganz transparent geworden das
ist etwas was wir uns auch hinter die
ohren schreiben müssen damit auch klar
ist wer sitzt wo und warum und was kann
diese kommission was kann sie auch nicht
und da haben wir einen gewissen
nachholbedarf und das ist auch meine
persönliche lehre dieses thema
transparenter und effizienter zu
gestalten und für die bevölkerung
einfach auch nachvollziehbarer zu machen
diese dynamik wir haben schon ein paar
mal darüber gesprochen
krieg ist eine dynamik in sich haben die
pandemie hat eine dynamik mit sich
gebracht die die ganz schwer
vorhersehbar ist und wenn sie dann da
ist ist sie schon zu schnell da wir
haben nie das richtige tempo irgendwie
haben das gefühl wir sind immer
hinterher wir wollen endlich in die
vorlage kommen
da bemühen wir uns ich hoffe das ist uns
im herbst gelingt zumindest gleich zu
kommen das hinterher jagen ist
zusätzlich etwas was unser schöpft
nämlich nicht nur körperlich so zu sagen
dass wir schon das gefühl habe chef zu
sein sondern das erschöpft uns dass wir
einfach geistig extrem und dieses dieses
diese ständige hinterher zu sein macht
diese pandemic fertig dieses
ich schaffe es einfach nicht mit dem
hinterher zu kommen das ist auch etwas
was viel viel stärker eingetreten ist
also es eigentlich beschrieben ist man
weiß das schon von wenn man nachlesen
über pandemien ja das ist zu
berücksichtigen oder das ist ein punkt
der
wahrscheinlich bei
geschenk kommt dass es sich tatsächlich
so auswirkt uns so stark betrifft glaube
ich ist auch eine gewisse form der
überraschung gewesen
datenmanagement ist auch ein thema wo
wir
sehen was wir könnten es ist nur so
komplex geworden in so vielen silos
gewachsen dass es wirklich nicht leicht
ist das jetzt wieder auf einen
gemeinsamen nenner zu bringen eine große
der lehre der pandemie ist bei jedem
daten thema das ich mache immer auf
diesen gesamtstaatlichen aspekt zu
schauen wir haben viele daten themen die
jeder für sich so entwickelt hat wo wir
jetzt wirklich alle gemeinsam große mühe
haben diese datensilos zu vereinigen so
dass sie sie wirklich auch zur verfügung
sind für die menschen mit diesen daten
umgehen wollen ich habe es gestern mit
meiner
abteilungsleitung für die impfung
angesprochen mit maria poliklinik die
gesagt hat wir sitzen nach so vielen
daten schätzen und dieses
wissenschaftlichen tut das schon so weh
dass uns so schwer fällt diese daten
entsprechend zu nutzen und deswegen wird
das einer der größten
themenblöcke seinem die wir im rahmen
unserer pandemischen aufarbeitung ich
glaube ich bewältigen müssen und auch
dass wir nicht in der öffentlichkeit
passieren das ist vollkommen klar
deswegen ist es hier besonders
wahrscheinlich schwierig zwischen welche
daten gehören wem und wozu brauchen wir
sie entsprechend aufzubereiten aber das
ist etwas was uns glaube ich ja wichtig
und
nicht allzu leicht fallen wird
was ja ich habe es am ende springe ich
drüber
ich möchte nur zum ebenfalls folgendes
sagen dass wir hier auch ein potenzial
haben dass wir viel mehr nach künftig
nutzen müssen uns eine große lehre der
pandemie ist nämlich die menschen
einzubeziehen dass daten thema besonders
und dann hat es ebenfalls zeigt sich wir
müssen die menschen beteiligen an ihrem
eigenen daten
an ihre eigenen daten produktion das ist
etwas was man persönlich generiert
sozusagen durch die durch die impfung wo
man aber mit einer form des ich bin hier
weil meine daten habe ich kann es auch
jemanden zur verfügung stellen ich weiß
wo ich sie finde wie wie kann ich sie
praktikabel mit mehr kennen jetzt den
grünen pass ist eine form von jaén fast
immer in der tasche haben der sich sogar
aktualisiert wenn sich irgendwelche
daten oder grenzen ändern das kann viel
mehr wir sind bei it-lösungen und bei
diesen
gesundheitsdaten ja nicht ganz vorne
dabei muss man sagen dass ich uns viele
nordische länder voraus dieses helfer da
tanja pokert und zwar auch die
gesundheitsdaten und damit nicht nicht
fast beschämt umzugehen sondern
transparent und und proaktiv umzugehen
dass wir ein weiterer punkt zu ändern
wir den wir angehen bei all den daten
thematiken wie sie für institutionen
brauchen ist dieses persönliche daten
dem was hat mich als bürger mit meinen
daten zu tun wie wie kann ich sie
steuern und nützen glaube ich eine eine
weitere herausforderung
ich hab es mitgenommen weil es weil
seine thematik war die uns von beginn an
beschäftigt hat und das bundesheer einen
großen anteil hat das thema der
beschaffung der logistik ist etwas was
originär ein bundesheer viel besser
aufgehoben ist es im
gesundheitsministerium
der bund kann das geschlecht dinge
beschaffen und verteilen das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr unsere
unsere kompetenz und deswegen ist uns
muss uns vollkommen klar sein dass wir
bezüglich unserer bevorratung man denke
nur die masken von frau bundesministerin
rauch kallat waren lange lange belegt
wir haben sie sehr lange aufgehoben und
gott sei dank so lange dass wir sie noch
gebraucht haben ich kann mich erinnern
wie wir den schaumstoff für den
nasenflügeln vielleicht erneuert haben
aber der rest der maske eigentlich ganz
hervorragend viele dinge die wir
vielleicht belächelt haben sie in der
pandemie groll des goldes wert und da
glaube ich haben wir die großen
lernprozess hinter uns gebracht
bevorratung lagerhaltung europäische
lokale produktionen nicht alles
auszulagern in weit entfernte länder wo
wir uns am flughafen darüber streiten
müssen werden die pakete gehören
sattelschlepper nicht über den brenner
kommen situation in dem den heutigen
jahrzehnten also den 2000er jahren
vielleicht noch noch noch ungewöhnlicher
sind jetzt schon davor war
auch die zeit muss ich schon ich bin
gleich fertig ein bindung von
stakeholdern
ganz grob gesprochen
länder bund sozialversicherung sind
nicht nur einer bundes ziel
steuerungskommission eine eine eine gut
eingerichtete struktur sondern sind in
der pandemie wichtiger denn je und auch
da glaube ich können wir zwischen dem
föderalismus und den zentralen
organisationen noch einiges mitnehmen
und das fazit das denn aus dem das den
lehrern bin wir meinen letzten zwei
folien
dann wenn es uns nicht mehr interessiert
sonst endlich besonders interessieren da
geht es vor allem darum unsere gesetz
entsprechend aufzurüsten wir haben das
krisen sicherheitsgesetz vor uns wir
haben novellierungen von gesetzen vor
uns die aus den 50er jahren stammenden
epidemie gesetz gesetze zu novellieren
wenn wir sie dringend brauchen ist keine
gute idee das wissen wir glaube ich auch
deswegen sollten uns alle die dinge die
wir nicht in der not oder aus der not
heraus machen sondern in der ruhephase
sollten sie uns umso wichtiger werden
und deswegen ist meine meine bitte meine
lehre an an uns alle dann wenn wir
anfangen uns nicht mehr dafür zu
infizieren ich glaube ich sollten uns
die dinge noch mehr interessieren dass
in der heißen phase ich hoffe dass wir
jetzt schon langsam in diese phasen
kommen wo wir in ruhe über manche dinge
nachdenken können und sie nicht in aus
der not heraus geschuldet adaptieren
müssen und auf diese zeiten freue ich
mich vielen dank
herzlichen dank erreicht
da möchte schließlich mit ihnen der sarg
auf dem blackout kommen sie waren seit
vielen jahren davor und versuchen auch
als präsident der gesellschaft der
krisenvorsorge darauf hinzuweisen dass
man sich vorbereiten sollte sie waren ja
auch office im bundestag jetzt ist es so
weit dass sich jeder haushalt damit
beschäftigt was könnte passieren wenn
wirklich das gas weg ge sondern die
gaskraftwerken nicht mehr funktionieren
was ist denn ihr ihre einschätzung der
risikolage derzeit
vielen dank und yoga thema zu bestreiten
dass eben noch nicht eingetreten ist zum
glück
und für viele doch noch nicht so greift
man es wie sie das gerade gesagt haben
dass viele menschen jetzt baugebiete
mehr nachdenken über vorsorge aber soll
ich die greifbar ist es nicht und wird
die frau bundesminister auch gesagt hat
wir schieben das lange genug hinaus bis
es dann wirklich da ist und wir haben
jetzt gerade durch die pandemie aber
auch durch den krieg vielleicht gelernt
wir sollten früher reagieren und ich
habe noch nicht das gefühl dass wir
wirklich das machen auch jetzt die gas
situation wir sind in der früh warnstufe
nur was heißt das bei mir rufen die
unternehmen ahnung was ist jetzt was
muss ich tun oder wie geht's weiter die
frage sollte ich stelle es heute vom
staat oder von ihnen beantwortet werden
welche weiteren maßnahmen sind oder
werden getroffen welche regelungen
kommen wenn es weiter eskaliert nicht in
der hoffnung dass es wirklich notwendig
ist aber da man sich vorbereiten kann
und gerade das thema black gott ist
jetzt zwar schon in aller munde erfasst
aber mir ist es sehr wichtig zu
definieren was ich darunter verstehe
weil ich leider nach wie vor erlebe dass
viele völlig unterschiedliche bildeten
und die meiner betrachtung geht es
einmal überregionalen das heißt mehr
weite teile europas oder zumindest
mehrere staaten betreffenden länger
unter strom das ist aber nur dass
auslöse ereignis aber es geht vor allem
um das infrastruktur- und am
versorgungsausfall und der versorgung
selbst weil es eben etwas das unsere
gesellschaft im status quo wie wir heute
aufgestellt sind neun millionen menschen
in österreich nach wenigen tagen das
genick brechen würde wirklich gerne
sprechen also dass sie in der partie nie
geschafft haben durch zeitpuffer das
wäre bei der beim black ort sofort alles
aus die gesamte versorgung und die
menschen sind großteils heute nicht
vorbereitet auch wenn setzt in den
letzten wochen vielleicht besser worden
ist aber wir wissen wir haben am ende
der ersten woche sechs millionen
menschen in österreich in etwa und wenn
es nur vier millionen sein ist auch egal
die im überlebenskampf sind die haben
nichts mehr zu essen sie sehen die
supermärkte sind leer oder zerstört und
es kommt nichts mehr woher soll was
kommen und sie haben letztes jahr eine
umfrage auch im rahmen des krone bendels
mitgestalten dürfen und 34 menschen
gesagt wenn das über mehrere wochen
versorgungsprobleme gibt uns der staat
fallen ja der staat wenn man richtig
versteht wie alle und unsere
hausaufgaben machten dann jetzt
funktionieren aber ich glaube das war
nicht die intention sondern staatliche
strukturen das bundesheer kommt wieder
ist jetzt immer gekommen und auch
erfolgreich bei der pandemie
9 millionen menschen kann niemand
versorgen und daher
risiko erkannt auch klar adressiert
darum darf ich auch hier sitzen aber ich
glaube wir müssen der kommunikation auch
finden ja nun aufklärung betreiben im
angst ist kein guter ratgeber aber
durchaus klartext sprechen wenn sich die
menschen darauf einstellen können
und auch diese vorsorge noch treffen
können und vor allem auch dass wieder
das übertriebene zu unterbinden weil
auch da jetzt der aktuelle situation
übertrieben viel mehl und öl einkaufen
weil das beweise knapp wird das nie
verwenden können das ist falsche
reaktion und da sind wir auch wieder bei
der unteren lernt das verteidigung und
weil die militärische schon intensiver
angesprochen und hier ist was zu tun
aber das große problem es uns fehlt die
basis dazu es fehlt die geistige
landesverteidigung als zivile
landesverteidigung und es fällt die
wirtschaftliche landesverteidigung das
heißt ja wir brauchen die strategische
reserve bundes jahr aber wenn es keine
verteidigungslinien der vorgibt und die
beginnen bei uns zu hause im eigenen
haushalt in der gemeinde dann gibt es
keine reserven mehr dahinter welt es ist
dann nicht mehr auffindbar und der sehr
wichtig wir müssen jetzt die geistige
landesverteidigung
massiv ansprechen dieses bewusstsein ja
wir gehen jetzt eine sehr turbulente
zeit durch den krieg jetzt massiv viele
lieferketten probleme bereits
losgetreten und ich fürchte wir werden
in den nächsten monaten
sehr weitreichende krisen erleben die
gas situation ist nur eines dass wir
kurzfristig möglich sollte es zur
unterbrechung kommen werden wir in den
nächsten wochen schon massivste
versorgungsprobleme haben ich hoffe das
wird sich hinaus schieben lassen aber
wir gehören nächsten winter kommen
wissen wir trotzdem nicht und er auch
wichtiges stichwort residenz schon
mehrfach gefallen auch da ist es mir
wichtig anzusprechen was ich darunter
verstehe weil meistens wird man
widerstandsfähigkeit verstanden der sie
lenz bedeutet aber anpassungen und
lernfähigkeit das heißt ja zu
realisieren so was ist möglich was
könnte das bedeuten die können wir
unsere abhängigkeiten senken wenn wir
mental darauf vorbereitet sind können
wir auch leichter damit umgehen
und ja strukturen ändern auch in der
wirtschaft wie der lagerhaltung wobei
wir jetzt schon mitten in der krise sind
oder mehreren krisen sind jetzt kommen
wahrscheinlich noch mehr gewesen es wird
immer schwieriger die preise steigen
explodieren bei mir rufen unternehmen
sagen sie wissen wie sie weiterfahren
sollen wenn sie aufhören dann geht zur
kette reaktionen der ganzen energiewende
oder in anderen bereichen weil einfach
wichtig wie der ausfall und werden auch
der wichtige punkt vernetzen
gesamtstaatliche betrachtung aus allen
blickwinkeln dass man jetzt noch eine
gewisse robustheit residenz aufbauen
aber nicht nur widerstandsfähigkeit
sondern auch anpassungen das bedeutet
auch wir müssen liebgewonnenes über bord
werfen das ein ganz wichtiger faktor
soccer hat katzmaier darüber auch vor
zwei jahren hier war resilienz bedeutet
im ressourcen freimachen um mit dem was
kommt oder neue ist person gehen zu
können und wir haben halt sehr viel
reguliert auch was in stabilen zeiten
sehr gut funktioniert und auch sinnvoll
war aber jetzt in krisenzeiten muss er
viele umbrüche auf uns zukommen müssen
wir wieder frei geschaffen um auf das
rascher reagieren zu können und es geht
nicht um papiere und so weiter sondern
um das tun und sagen jetzt auch mehrfach
gehört wir wissen schon wir zeichnen uns
aus aber die konsequenzen daraus die
ableitung und wirklich die handlungen da
braucht es noch mehr und er braucht uns
alle nicht nur die
sicherheitseinrichtungen sondern die
gesamte bevölkerung
herzlichen dank aber zurück danke
für ihre stetige vorbereitung der
bevölkerung in den letzten jahren davor
ich glaube viele bereiten sich vor wenn
roman dazu gelesen haben auf ihrer
arbeit beruht ich würde jetzt gerne in
der diskussion einsteigen ich weiß es
sind dann sehr aufmerksames publikum
immer ich weiß aber auch dass es mit
masken wahrscheinlich schwieriger ist es
das erste mal jetzt seit zwei jahren wgc
energie
sie sind danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
ist sehr sehr fokussiert ja ich würde
gern einsteigen noch mal zurückkommen so
aktuellen situation wenn man in puts
gehört das was
sich in der bevölkerung sehr viele
fragen und ich in sicherheitskreisen
auch immer höherer ist die frage ist so
wie wahr wie groß ist die gefahr dass
dieser krieg auch über die grüne hinaus
geht also richtung westeuropa rückt ich
möchte vielleicht in die runde fragen
vielleicht geben sie mir ein handzeichen
wer in der hier von ihnen der meinung
ist man sollte sich darauf vorbereiten
dass dieser krieg über die ukraine
hinausgeht geben sie mir mal die hand
wer das denkt auch
der general das immer beim erster hälfte
und wer hat den eindruck dass europa
darauf vorbereitet ist
also niemand auch die mieter general ich
gebe ihnen das wort ich würde gerne eine
runde machen dazu verlegt weil wenn man
sich mit risiken auseinandersetzt dann
muss man sich mit diesem risiko
auseinandersetzen und wir haben sie mit
einer atommacht zu tun
wie groß schätzen sie das risiko ein
dass krieg über die ukraine hinausgeht
dass die nato in den krieg vielleicht
doch ein tritt im prinzip ist europa
eingetreten durch waffenlieferungen aber
nicht auf dem boden
general
ja dieser konflikt hat viele
unwägbarkeiten mit sich gebracht und
das spannungsfeld sehe ich darin dass
natürlich die autokratische führung in
russland versucht sein könnte ihren
handlungsspielraum auszutesten
das heißt mal auszutesten ja ist es
wirklich eine
konzentrierte
antwort der nato wenn beispielsweise das
baltische territorium in die russischen
maßnahmen mit eingeschlossen würde oder
anders gefragt würde das eine kollektive
reaktion hervorrufen und natürlich nach
dem artikel 5 des atlantischen vertrages
selbstverständlich aber bis zu welchen
eskalation sgw werde es sich der westen
sozusagen leisten in eine solche
konformation die ja letztlich auch eine
nukleare komponente hat einzusteigen
somit besteht dieses spannungsfeld für
mich darin dass ein autokratisches
regime eben versucht sein könnte einen
solchen test anzustellen insbesondere
wenn der eindruck entsteht dass trotz
aller sanktionen und waffenlieferungen
eigentlich
der handlungsspielraum russland zu
mindestens mittelfristig nicht
wesentlich eingeschränkt ist sondern sie
haben natürlich ihre strategischen ziele
nicht erreicht aber sie haben die
operation auch nicht beenden müssen ich
möchte vielleicht damit mal belassen
sie waren ja auch in nato defence
institut tätig sie haben einblick was
was ist ihrer einschätzung
das ist genau das automatisch an also
die die typisch akademische antwort wäre
das hängt davon ab wie groß ist die
gefahr eines krieges also ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen erstens
was mich wirklich wild macht ist wenn
leute hergehen und anfangen
wahrscheinlichkeiten aufzustellen dass
ich habe wirklich sachen gehört wie wir
haben eine 25 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es einen
atomschlag gibt oder 20 prozent oder 8
prozent also da haben sie in mathematik
nicht aufgepasst wenn sie so was machen
denn sie brauchen eine gemütliche eine
groß genug gross genug sein konnte schon
deutsch mehr sie brauchen eine gewisse
anzahl von daten irgendwo überhaupt zum
beispiel so etwas berechnen zu können
also das bauchgefühl ist keine
datenbasis deswegen das ist das
allererste wir müssen ganz klar sagen
wir wissen es nicht wir können keine
zahl darauf kleben jetzt gerade thomalla
totschlag atomschlag deswegen ist ihre
frage dass der krieg zu uns kommt in
welcher form also es übermäßig ist ja
schon da reden wir jetzt von clutches an
der grenze zwischen polnischen
weißrussischen russischen truppen wenn
das lokal begrenzt ist ist der krieg
dann theoretisch in europa ja aber
natürlich haben wir keine panzer die
durch wien rollen also wird immer die
frage da werden jetzt szenarien zum
beispiel wichtig dass mal auszuführen
was können wir uns vorstellen unsere
beste datenbasis ist nämlich die
vorstellungskraft was wäre möglich und
wie gehen wir damit um was wir wissen
ist aus der militärischen doktrin der
russen dass solange wir uns nicht weiter
einmischen heißt das was wir bis jetzt
gemacht haben also nicht flugverbotszone
auf keinen fall irgendwas on the ground
ich persönlich bin auch sehr kritisch
gegenüber diesen internationalen
bataillon ich weiß nicht ob sie davon
gehört haben manche mitgliedsstaaten
ermutigen ihre bürger sich dem
anzuschließen das finde ich ist ehrlich
sage rechtlich schon eine grauzone
solange wir es also so belassen wie
jetzt geben wir russland keinen grund
uns in irgendeiner form draufzuhauen das
heißt natürlich nicht dass sie das nicht
machen werden man kann natürlich jetzt
sich vorstellen das ist jetzt
interessanter im krieg ist dass es
ebenso viele überraschungs elemente hat
so emotionale und ich sage in
anführungsstrichen rationelle das sagen
jetzt mal putting geht nach hause muss
irgendwie und dann haut einfach mal
drauf nur um mac point aber darf ich
dann mal nachfragen weil also ist ja
nicht so dass russland sich seine gründe
nicht fabrizieren könnte das sehen wir
ja jeden tag sind wir das
außenministerium genannt und wenn man
sie sind zwar erst gesagt man hört so
wenig zu und ließ das zu wenig wenn man
aber die russischen papieren ließ der
zeit dann steht da nicht nur drinnen
ukraine steht auch der einen moldawien
und da steht auch drin im baltikum
sollte man das ernst jetzt ernst nehmen
so wie es vorher gesagt ich werde mich
auf jeden fall ernst nehmen aber da die
kunst der frosch ist ja immer nicht so
sehr die panik zu verfallen sie haben es
gerade schon gesagt warum das ist
wirklich neurologisch so dass wenn sie
ist ja der amicale hijack also ein
bereich ihres gehirns wenn der alarm
schlägt dann können sie nur angreifen
oder sich nach liegen aber sie können
nicht mehr rational denken oder auch
sich nur überlegen was gibt es
eigentlich für optionen ist ganz wichtig
dass sie nicht in die angst verfallen
wenn es nötig ist schauen sie sich
einfach mal zwei tage lang nicht die
nachrichten an aber man muss natürlich
schon durchkalkulieren war davon aber
ich
bin nicht zu ihrer arbeitslosigkeit
beitragen nur so ein zwei tage ab und
alles um freies wochenende
aber es ist schon wichtig glauben sie
gesagt haben man muss alles mit kühlem
kopf einmal durch kalk kollegen was wenn
man sich vorstellt wir haben ja ich
empathie wenn wir uns in moskau
hineinversetzen was wäre denkbar was
könnten die tun was können wir tun uns
darauf vorzubereiten denn natürlich sind
wir nicht darauf vorbereitet wir sind
mental natürlich noch im vorher wir sind
wir sind sehr viel besser als mit cyber
zum beispiel aber so territoriale
kriegsführung das können die amerikaner
halt besser als wir gott sei dank aber
deswegen ich würde sagen unsere stärkste
waffe ist die vorstellungskraft aber
ganz wichtig zwischen wunschdenken und
panik das ist genau der sweet spot genau
der in der mitte herr general nicht noch
eine frage anziehen
die nukleare abschreckung funktioniert
zwar weil man hat den eindruck sie
funktioniert nur in eine richtung also
europa und die nato sind sehr sehr
darauf habe ich genau die regeln
einzuhalten bis hin zu den bataillonen
und ja kein flugzeug wir kriegen zu
lassen was der ukraine fordert umgekehrt
hat man nicht den eindruck dass boten
sich sonderlich
abgeschreckt fühlt oder denn das sehr
ernst nimmt wenn er ja dinge tut die
nicht der rechtslage entsprechen bino
kräne einmarschieren wie kann man denn
diese dieses ungleichgewicht in der
angst voreinander sozusagen das
ungleichgewicht des schreckens jetzt
bewerten
sie sprechen die nukleare komponente an
die gefahr sehe ich und manche analysten
darin dass wenn also ein durchschlag in
der erfolg der russin in der ukraine in
absehbarer zeit nicht erzielbar ist dass
sie dann taktische atomwaffen einsetzen
was ja immer noch keinen konflikt mit
der nato
normiert sozusagen nach sich zieht weil
es ja nicht nato territorium betreffe
und das unter umständen dann der
russischen taktischen einsatz trug turin
folgend eine solche eine solche
eskalation erfolgen könnte ich glaube
aber auch dass auch die russische
führung davon so weit als möglich
abstand nehmen wird weil ja auch das
internationale echo entsprechend negativ
wäre und mit weiteren maßnahmen zu
rechnen während sein ist auch nur
neuerliche
restriktive maßnahmen im handel und
wandel
was ich aber noch
anfügen wollte zu dem aspekt empathie
der hier angesprochen wurde natürlich
muss man mitdenken wie diese russische
seite
info der führung putins den konflikt
anlegt und begründet und hier schwingt
ja immer wieder mit dass die ost
erweiterung der nato sozusagen
nicht paktiert war so man im gegenteil
ein versprechen abgegeben wurde wenn das
auch historisch jetzt nicht einwandfrei
nachweisbar ist dass dieser cordon
sanitaire erhalten bleibt und daraus
leitet putin in seiner denke eine
gewisse legitimität ab diesem zustand
auf der historischen ebene
sukzessive wieder zu beheben sowie china
etwa taiwan wieder vereinnahmen wird und
deshalb wird auch wie es hier auch schon
gesagt wurde nach dem ende eines ukraine
konfliktes wie auch immer er kompromiss
haft ausfallen wird die geschichte nicht
zu ende sein sondern das größere
russland wird thema bleiben
wie lange kann europa zu sehen bei
dieser eskalation herr müller es hat ja
eine fast erstaunlich als
beobachterinnen erstaunlich geschlossene
schnelle reaktion gegeben europa zählte
ukraine quasi zu sichern wurden beitritt
versprechen abgegeben zumindest
kandidaten versprechen abgegeben und man
jetzt finden massaker statt
welche eskalationsstufen sind dann noch
europa sagt sowie schrauben ein bisschen
an der sanktionsschraube oder wo werden
die rufe laut werden diese wie wir sie
aus der beide kommunen ja jetzt schon
dann tatsächlich einzugreifen
chemiewaffen taktischer atomwaffen und
was da alles jetzt nicht so
unrealistisch und
ja ich weiß jetzt nicht genau was sie
mit zuschauen meinen ja so ich denke da
ich meinen die rufe nach dem
militärischen eingreifen die sie aus dem
baltikum und polen gekommen wie sehr
wird das in den rest von europas
vordringen wenn da weitere zum beispiel
massaker stattfinden oder chemie waffen
eingesetzt dann ja gut ich meine dass
man jetzt vielleicht dinge die man nicht
vorweg nehmen möchte ich glaube dass
europa und auch die nato sehr
sehr gut abgewogen reagiert hat man hat
herten gezeigt auch in dem sanktions
bereich die wichtig sind aber man hat
auch aufgepasst dass man nicht insofern
über agiert dass man die dinge die man
nicht haben möchte dann am ende auch
mitproduziert ja das ist ja auch immer
die gefahr
wie reagiert russland auf aktionen die
die eu setzt und da muss man immer auch
mit denken dass man auch das verhindert
was man nicht haben möchte und hier ist
ja ganz eine ganz wichtige linie dass
die sache überschwappt dann auch auf
nato staaten mit all den konsequenzen
die das dann hat ich denke was sehr
wichtig ist ist dass man sehr klare
signale umsetzt artikel 5 gilt dass man
auch stärke zeigt dass man diese staaten
auch unterstützt weil natürlich die
sorge in diesen staaten ganz groß ist
und selbst wenn nichts passieren würde
aber man im wald kommt das gefühl hat
man wurde nicht hinreichend unterstützt
und gestärkt in der situation hat das
natürlich auch nachwirkungen
das gleiche gilt für länder wie polen
und so weiter ja wie man jetzt auf all
diese szenarien reagieren heute htc
vorwegnehmen ich glaube da ist man gut
beraten das vielleicht gar nicht auch zu
expliziten dass man sehr deutlich macht
man wird mit ja vieles ist denkbar aber
man muss das nicht unbedingt glaube ich
konkretisieren das würde ich strategisch
nicht für sinnvoll halten und letzter
punkt da wir haben es mit einer
atommacht zu tun
die dinge tut ja die einen abstoßen die
schrecklich sind ja aber man darf das
nicht aus dem auge verlieren ja
herzlichen dank dann würde ich dann den
schritt machen von der von vom konkreten
krieg vom militärischen krieg zum
wirtschaftsweg cyber krieg in dem wir ja
schon drinnen stecken und das nicht nur
von russischer seite sondern das ist ein
bedrohungsszenario dass ich schon seit
vielen jahren in der risiko landschaft
findet er sei ob sie haben schon noch
mal angemahnt dass wir nicht so
vorbereitet sind wie wir sein sollten
jetzt haben wir diese gas situation
was müsste denn passieren damit
europa aber auch in kleinere länder wie
österreich resilient da werden gegenüber
lieferketten die durchbrochen sind
gaslieferungen die stoppen können und so
weiter also es gibt in das system
wissenschaft modell das notwendig ist um
ein lebensfähiges systeme zu stärken das
beginnt mit ressourcenbedarf senkung
energiebedarf senkung das heißt eine
genau hier anzusetzen und wir werden die
energiewende nicht schaffen mit dem
hohen niveau an energieverbrauch den wir
heute haben also da ist der größte hebel
war jede energie die wir nicht
benötigten brauchen wir nicht
produzieren braucht man nicht speichern
und wieder dem zuträglich sein dann geht
es um dezentrale strukturen weil
komplexe systeme sich eben nicht zentral
steuern lassen das heißt nicht dass man
jetzt alles futteral und kleinteilig
macht aber robuste strukturen schafft
mal durchaus mit dezentraler
handlungsfähigkeit und der föderalismus
otto in gewissen bereichen durchaus
einen vorteil wenn man es dann halt
nicht wieder überspannt und es gibt
dinge die man gemeinsam angehen muss und
der dritte punkt die dritte säule des
fehler freundlichkeit fehlertoleranz das
heißt dass man auch mit störungen
umgehen können muss und da sind die
entweder aus gesellschaft gefordert
nicht der erwartung aufrecht zu halten
so wie vor der bande gesetzt damit er
weiter nein das ist jetzt mal sicher für
die nächsten jahre dahin wir kommen
jetzt in die turbulente zeit durch diese
ganze lieferketten unterbrechungen und
es wird langfristig sicher wieder besser
weitergehen wir müssen es nur schaffen
jetzt kurzfristig das auch über lena
also nicht nur die hoffnung ja es geht
immer positiv weiter weil wir sehr hohes
niveau haben auch energie mäßig und
wirtschaftlich vernetzt und wenn das
größer gestört ist dann auch das
natürlich schwer die kollateralschäden
aber das beginnt auch wieder mit grund
überlebensfähigkeit eigenversorgung
stetigkeit die regionalen versorgung
wieder zu stärken weil das ist das erste
was man brauchen dann hört die
lagerhaltung auch die schon angesprochen
wurde dezentrale erzeugung möglichkeiten
auch beispiele aus meinem bereich
gesundheitswesen auch wir haben die
selbst produktion von ring lösung das
ist die basis für fast jede behandlung
abgeschafft dass man selbst herstellen
kann weil das ist zu teuer das wird
jetzt alles importiert und das war schon
beim ersten lockdown das problem an die
grenzen schließen dann kommt nimmer
und das heißt das heißt nicht dass wir
die quali sieren komplett über bord
werfen immer so war es auch sondern das
was wirklich überlebenswichtig ist das
muss man definieren den
unterschiedlichen bereichen zumindest
möglichst dezentral auch vor ort
herstellen zu können
zu lagern und dann kann man das ganze
natürlich weiterhin optimieren so wie es
jetzt gemacht haben aber wir haben heute
nur alles immer auf die positive seite
gelegt und hinschaut und das was heute
schattenseiten sind völlig aus den augen
verloren und das ist die große gefahr
die wir derzeit vor uns haben der
general das hat ja auch schon professor
müller gesagt dass die eu sich darauf
verlassen hat dass sie die
internationale vernetzung etwas
positiver sonders weiterbringen wird sie
sind ja jetzt ab juni dieses jahres
vorsitzender des militärausschusses
herzliche gratulation an dieser stelle
sei eine ehre für österreich dass das so
passiert und haben ja schon in mir am
eingang steht man es diese umfassende
verteidigungsstrategie benannt wie sehr
werden sie sich auf solche
wirtschaftlichen aspekte auch in bezug
auf china
vorbereiten auf die urheber numbers wenn
sie da tun
ja in der europäischen union gibt es
natürlich zahlreiche agenturen die
gerade dieses thema als eigenständige
aufgabe zu betreiben haben die aufgabe
des militärausschusses wird es sein hier
natürlich auch beratend zur verfügung zu
stehen und auf die notwendigkeit der
versorgungssicherheit und
diversifizierung der verschiedenen
ressourcen zuweisen insofern ist es auf
der eu-ebene ähnlich oder noch stärker
vernetzt wie die hier schon mehrfach
angesprochene umfassende
landesverteidigung eine umfassende
sicherheitsvorsorge für die union die
für ihre bürgerinnen und bürger eine
eine sichere zukunft und eine
vernünftige perspektive diese zukunft
auch zu bewahren beinhaltet
dann möchte ich zu einer zweiten
bedrohung kommen die heute mehrfach
angesprochen worden ist bringt er vor
was ihrem sie eingebracht die ministerin
die desinformation
frage ob sie an gesagt das russische
außenministerium ist geradezu kläglich
fast lächerlich in seinem tweet
was man aber schon also zumindest wir
feststellen was bei uns landeten dass
die talking points und die verwirrung
strategien die ja dann gestreut werden
in der breite sehr sehr wohl ankommen
und also schon langsam sich nach einer
kleinen pause einer seltsamen in den
ersten zehn tagen des krieges sich sehr
stark verbreiten in der bevölkerung
das haben hat russland der
perfektioniert aber nicht nur russland
das ist eine allgemeine bedrohung wie
hoch schätzen sie die gefahr für den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft sein dass
informationen kommt also etwas was
interessant ist also russische
propaganda weil das ist es ja hat zwei
komponenten des eines zweifels sehen
also es reicht schon wenn irgendeiner
nur zweifel butter waren das vielleicht
doch nicht die russen vielleicht wann
tatsächlich die ukraine selber einfach
so zweifel in den in die köpfe bringen
und das zweite ist wiederholung und das
ist also der zweifel entsteht auch
dadurch dass man immer und immer und
immer wieder das gleiche sagt sind es
wenn es noch so absurd es irgendwann
wird ihr gehen anfangen zu denken
vielleicht ist es ja doch war und das
machen sie natürlich ganz konsequent
jetzt auch bezug auf die ukraine was ich
aber nicht sehe ist also die sind halt
jetzt so übers ziel hinausgeschossen
also solche sachen wie das halt dass das
nazis sind in der ukraine oder eben das
mit butscher dass es zu keiner selber
waren ich habe das gefühl das ist jetzt
schon das ist fast er für die eigene
bevölkerung gedacht als für unsere weil
ich sehe also sie haben schon recht
manche sachen fangen an so so durch zu
sichern ganz beliebt es ja zum beispiel
dieses motiv und keine gibt es ein
künstlicher staat oder gibt es gar nicht
also falls ich das auch glauben nein das
ist historischer quatsch und ukrainisch
ist nicht russisch ist eine eigene
sprache ist im polnischen er so ich weiß
dass ich das alles wissen aber dass
solche sachen sich schon an das finde
ich ein bisschen beunruhigen die gute
nachricht ist also hoffe ich wird dass
wir eigentlich schon seit acht jahren
darüber reden dass die russen
desinformation betreiben und dass wir
besser darin sein müssen sachen zu
erkennen dass wir auf dieser effekt
jagger und
wenn sie nicht wenn fotos gepostet
werden da hat man gleich eine ganze
menge an leuten die überprüfen woher
kommen die und so weiter und so weiter
also das dichte glaube wir sind besser
gewappnet als jetzt noch vor acht jahren
aber ja propaganda man ist nie ganz
davor gefeit dass es halt irgendwie
durchsickert aber dann will ich den ball
auch zurück ich frage mich halt wie
sieht auf russischer seite aus inwiefern
haben wir da an impact was dringt durch
von auch seelands gis nachrichten ich
wurde gestern gefragt was würden sie
selent gs kommunikationsberaterin jetzt
raten ich würde sagen versuche in den
russischen raum rein zu kommen weil da
ist ja eigentlich die wichtigste debatte
vielleicht klassisch mit flugblättern
oder irgendwie man sich in fernsehsender
ein hacken ich bin kein hacker
wahrscheinlich das viel schwieriger als
ich mir vorstelle aber ich denke
propaganda geht auch in die andere
richtung und da würde mich interessieren
wie sehen die russen das gerade ob wir
unsere propaganda in anführungsstrichen
bei denen wirkt willst du nicht gerade
so dass ich ihnen das wort dazu gebe ich
möchte aber dann noch zur pandemie und
desinformation kommen
ich teile da einige einschätzung was ich
glaube was natürlich wichtig es ist zu
sehen dass wir ja in liberalen offenen
gesellschaften leben das heißt wir
schätzen medien freiheiten wir schätzen
auch freie meinungsäußerung dass es
natürlich in autokratischen staaten
anders
das heißt die mechanismen autokratischen
staaten sich solchen informationen zu
verschließen auch die machtmechanismen
sind stark das heißt da hat man dann
natürlich auch eine gewisse asymmetrie
der zweite punkt ist auch desinformation
und all diese kampagnen wo schauen wir
sie uns an ja wenn wir jetzt den
baltischen staaten gehen wo wir
russischsprachige minderheiten haben ja
da sind wir natürlich in viel ich hätte
jetzt gesagt virulenten situationen aber
das wort würde ich ja gar nicht gerne in
den mund nimmt wenn wir weder auch so
viel mit carola zu tun haben ist
wahrscheinlich auch schon ein gewisser
über sättigungsgrad ja aber das sind
natürlich die verwundbarkeiten groß ja
und ich würde das sehr ernst nehmen ja
also wir haben ja wenn wir jetzt sagen
man möchte zweifel säen man möchte auch
zwietracht säen schauen wir uns doch mal
an die polarisierung in vielen
europäischen staaten ja schauen wir uns
an dass wir
ja in ungarn welche regierung wir da
haben wir dies nicht positioniert so
europäischen werten wie es die
ministerien umstrukturieren wie sieht
die ausbildung von diplomaten
umstrukturieren welche
wertevorstellungen da hinein kommen was
das für ein europa und für das
funktionieren von europa bedeutet ja und
das sind viele so kräfte auch zum
beispiel die flüchtlings thematik man
kann das sehr positiv sehen momentan ja
es stimmt ich teile vollkommen was sie
gesagt haben es ist eine ganz große
bereitschaft dieser staaten darauf zu
reagieren aber wenn russland langfristig
denkt dann weiß ich nicht was die
integration von vier millionen
flüchtlingen langfristig in diesen
staaten bedeutet und wie eine stimmung
auch irgendwann kippen kann ich weiß
dass wir hier in österreich mit
willkommensgrüßen und sträußen an
bahnhöfen standen und syrische
flüchtlinge in dieser welle unterstützt
haben ja aber eine kurzfristige aufnahme
oder ein weiter winken nach deutschland
ja oder wie auch immer ist doch etwas
anderes als langfristige prozesse und
genauso sehe ich das mit der
desinformation da würde ich auch denken
damit sollte man sich befassen mit
capture und wir werden nichts da denken
viele punkte die die mal gewichtig sind
das geht ja auch weiter über russland
hinaus vielleicht noch mal eine frage an
sie im raum wer von ihnen waschung
konfrontiert mit so russischen talking
points zu kleine krise im bekanntenkreis
auf seinen sozialen netzwerken wer hat
das schon so gehört zum beispiel dieser
zweifel zu rutschen den letzten tagen
schon viele oder und hat zur pandemie
wer war da konfrontiert den
bekanntenkreis oder im unmittelbaren mit
verschwörungstheorien zweifeln da
wundert mich jetzt was das nicht alle
aufzeigen ist eine große mehrheit hat
auch eine russische komponente das war
ja nicht zuletzt auch eine
destabilisierung strategie sich dar
einzuklinken aber ja nicht nur wie
resilient sind wir geworden oder wie
wenig resilienz intrige geworden
gegenüber desinformation
verschwörungstheorien
schwierige frage ich
residieren sie ist für mich ja die
anpassungsfähigkeit und
vivi wie sehr wir präsident sein können
haben wir haben wir gezeigt ich glaube
was wir ganz schlecht aushalten ist und
das kann man glaube ich nicht trainieren
das endet in einer erschöpfung ist
dieses thema dieser dieser wenn ich
nicht mehr weiß dass es eine
desinformation ist wenn ich das auch
nicht mehr unterscheiden kann so leicht
sondern das ineinander verschwindet wenn
mir wenn mir zu viele widersprüchliche
botschaften kommen wo ich mir nicht
sicher bin eigentlich kommt das alles
aus mir seriös erscheinenden quellen sie
widersprechen sich aber trotzdem in
meiner wahrnehmung und da spreche jetzt
gar nicht von offensichtlichen
verschwörungstheorien mit dem wir werden
alle über die waden geimpft werde den
kanaldeckeln wir nichts über
kanaldeckeln also das sind absurde
themen das können wir leicht
identifizieren aber wo glaube ich bei
uns die erschöpfung oder die
desinformation herkommt ist dass wir
sehr oft ein thema von zwei seiten
besprechen oft rein wissenschaftlich und
beides ist nicht falsch aber es fehlt
uns das manchmal das hintergrundwissen
dazu oder die aufbereitete diskussion
dazu um zu erkennen das ist überhaupt
das widerspricht sich eigentlich nicht
ich muss noch intensiver darüber
nachdenken und das haben weder zeit noch
energien nach möglichkeit auf damit den
entsprechenden gremien oder im
entsprechenden gruppen das zu besprechen
und das ist glaube ich die schwierigkeit
dass wir die desinformation oder die
mangel informationen schwer
auseinanderhalten können in der pandemie
und ja eine frage noch haben sie herr
general die eu hat der stelle gegen der
information eingerichtet also kümmert
sich um das thema allerdings wenn man
sich so die budgets anschaut vermutlich
mit weniger budget als die anderen denen
diesen das informations kampf drinnen
sind ist geplant dass
ernster zu nehmen in zukunft und mehr zu
tun ja das würde in dem bereich residenz
des strategischen kompasses fallen und
nochmals es ist derzeit die ankündigung
was die eu und was wir alle zu tun
beabsichtigen und das muss natürlich
vor dem hintergrund des politischen
willens es auch wirklich umzusetzen auch
finanziert werden also
verglichen jetzt mit materiellen
aufwendungen ist die ausstattung von
desinformations mechanismen um das also
entsprechend zurück zu weisen sind
anzuhalten ja finanziell keine so große
angelegenheit wenn man das mit mit mit
einsatz systemen vergleicht aber dennoch
muss es auch mit berücksichtigt werden
ich kann auch sagen konzeptionell ist es
vorhanden ich hoffe für eine umsetzung
dann würde ich sie einladen zu einem
kurzen schluss statement unter einer
minute wenn es geht das eine
zusammenfassung ihres aufrufs für den
nächsten zwölf monaten
das ist ja immer für das jahr 2022 es
wird dann im herbst beginnen das neue
schreiben unseren neuen risiko
landschaft barock was ist ihre abschluss
botschaft in dieser runde
ja das ist schon gesagt hat wir müssen
an die öffentlichkeit gehen auch wenn
dem viele menschen krisen müde sind aber
wir müssen das jetzt klarer ansprechen
diese chance noch zu nutzen um vorsorge
anzukurbeln es gibt gespräche mit dem
lebensmittelhandel das auch über die
dachmarke mach mit österreich wird
krisen fit zu machen
aber wir müssen in strom kommen unser
größtes problem ist das tun und die
menschen auch darauf vorzubereiten dass
eben in den nächsten jahren mit viel
turbulenz zu rechnen ist wenn man eben
diese bereitschaft man hat sich darauf
einzulassen dann kann man auch leichter
nehmen was immer kommt herr professor
müller was soll ein kleineres land wie
österreich ein neutrales land in diesem
fall verteidigungspolitisch tun um sich
vorzubereiten und zu rüsten
ja das wäre vielleicht ein längeres
statement aber was mir wichtig ist ist
wirklich dass man man ist ein kleines
land aber man ist in europa man ist teil
eines systems was nur zusammen
funktioniert und ich glaube diese
aufgabe sehr ernst zu nehmen dass es
ganz wichtig also es ist kein moment wo
man trittbrettfahren sollte es keinen
moment wo man denkt ja damit hat man
nichts zu tun das regeln die großen ja
ist es ein wenn es teil
eines großen blocks in der welt und in
dem rahmen muss man seine verantwortung
wahrnehmen und das auch sehr aktiv
frau reicht
vielleicht ganz kurz zusammengefasst
bremen in bezug auf das bundesheer
wollte ich sind fangen also was ist da
in bezug auf landesverteidigung ihrer
abschluss
empfehlung vielleicht gilt das für das
bundesheer wie für die pandemie ich
glaube prävention ist manchmal besser
als reaktion
das wird vielleicht beide beide welten
gut zusammenfassen und
die
glaube ich auch gleiche gleiche
grundlage in beiden welten gilt es muss
uns dann weiter interessieren wenn es
uns eigentlich nicht mehr interessiert
vorbereitung aufstockung
ressourcen personal aufzustellen
infrastruktur herzurichten auf zu
aufzufahren
das gelingt in zeiten wo es uns
eigentlich wo man eigentlich nicht
brauchen wahrscheinlich besser
frau auf sie haben am anfang gesagt was
hier natürlich alles sehr gerne hören
dass österreich sich immer sehr früh
gedanken macht und sich strategisch gut
vorbereitet was wäre ihre empfehlung
verteidigungspolitisch in dieser lage
das wird das erst mal nicht
und etwas ironisch erscheinen aber ich
finde was wichtig ist ist was ich
vorzeitig jene nenne das heißt schauen
sie sich mal ihre alten berichte an und
messen sie wo haben wir überschätzt wo
haben wir unterschätzt wenn sie das
regelmäßig machen dann werden sie immer
besser darin die zukunft richtig
einzuschätzen also ich persönlich mache
das auch dann kann man auch sie haben
auch gesagt folgenreiche man will ja
auch mal in der volks erlebnis haben
dann wird vielleicht auch bewusst hey da
lagen wir da nicht so falsch und haben
wir auch richtige sachen gemacht recht
will ich das noch österreich empfehlen
und ob das was sie eh schon tun du hast
ja auch sehr gut machen und das weil ich
schon gesagt sie müssen leider gottes
auch die anderen ministerien hinzuholen
auch die bevölkerung dass es insgesamt
glaube ich in zukunft senken kann nicht
nur im militär stattfinden weil wir sind
nicht mehr im 19 jahrhundert
herzlichen dank herr general da möchte
ich ihnen das schlusswort geben wir sind
heute schon mehrmals höhere budgets
gefordert worden diese diskussion führen
wir seit jahren das ist denn konkret
notwendig aus ihrer sicht für das
österreichische bundesheer für das
österreichische bundesheer haben wir für
die notwendige beseitigung unserer
fähigkeitslücken drei große körbe wenn
ich sie so lernt auf identifiziert das
erste betrifft die mobilität
sowohl land als auch der
luftstreitkräfte die in der lage sein
müssen geschützt sozusagen sich zu
bewegen auf dem gefechtsfeld um auch den
soldaten die chance zu geben ihren
auftrag zu erfüllen und wenn möglich
gesund wieder nach hause zu kommen das
zweite ist schutz und wirkung das hat
natürlich mit dem ersten unmittelbar zu
tun beginnt bei der mannes ausrüstung
bis hin zur notwendigkeit
präzisionsmunition einzuführen weil es
eben und man sieht es auch in der
ukraine in einem urbanen gefechtsfeld
darauf ankommt möglichst wenig
kollateralschäden zu erzeugen und
dennoch bestimmte militärische ziele
ausschalten zu können und das dritte ist
resilienz und autarkie wir sind da
rangegangen unsere militärischen
einrichtungen unsere kasernen so
auszustatten wir haben damit begonnen
das sie 14 tage in der lage sind sich
eigen zu versorgen die die
handlungsfähigkeit des militärs jetzt
für militärische aber auch zivile
aufgaben zu erhalten sozusagen als
strategische reserve wie das die frau
bundesminister auch immer wieder
angesprochen hat auch das erfordert
investitionen die zahlen da möchte ich
mich jetzt nicht einlassen sie sind
mehrfach genannt worden was ich
sozusagen am ende allen
entscheidungsträgern als bitte ans herz
legen würde ist nicht nachzulassen in
den anstrengungen weil uns nützt eine
milliarde jetzt am fleck nichts sondern
wir brauchen über einen langen zeitraum
der entwicklung und streitkräfte
entwickeln sich über jahrzehnte eine
nachhaltige gesicherte und sukzessiv
steigende finanzierung das ist meine
bitte an die entscheidungsträger und
damit möchte ich auch schließen besten
dank herzlichen dank herr gerne rein
und eines gedanken
vielen dank für die ausgezeichnete
diskussion ist darf sie bitten noch
sitzen zu bleiben weil ich möchte jetzt
zu den schlussworten den kabinettschef
von über leitungs verantwortlichen in
der gt verteidigungspolitiker kann das
verteidigungsministerium auf die bühne
bitten anhalt kamen bitte geben sie uns
einen kurzen abschluss vielen herzlichen
dank frau mit born meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren nachdem ich im
unterschied zu ihnen gerade die
gleichsam vorösterliche erlösung der
fahrer die maske abnehmen zu dürfen aber
andererseits weiß wie es ihnen in den
letzten zwei stunden ergangen ist weil
ich versuchen nicht das rad neu zu
erfinden und repetitiv noch auf die
einzelnen punkte einzugehen sondern
vielleicht anhand von drei konkreten
schlagwörtern
ihnen einiges mit auf den weg zu geben
und auch der hoffnung ausdruck zu
verleihen dass wir diese schlagwörter
nicht nur solche aufnehmen sondern auch
beginnen entsprechend zu leben und
entsprechend darum zu setzen erster
schlagwort umdenken wir haben viel heute
am heutigen vormittag gehört von
zensuren
zeitenwenden helfried möglich schreibt
in seinem beitrag vom wandel der
globalen weltordnung
auch wenn wir unsere eigenen
strategischen dokumente im rahmen der
europäischen union her nehmen manche
davon wurden bereits zitiert so sehen
wir auch hier eine gewissen wandel
lassen sie mich kurz zurückblicken das
jahr 2003 wir ich war damals auch noch
mehr auf der akademischen seite haben
uns alle sehr gefreut über die
europäische sicherheitsstrategie von
2003 die damit begonnen hat das europa
noch nie so frei so sicher und so
wohlhabend war 19 jahre später sieht die
realität anders aus aber was uns in
diesen 19 jahren ironisch gemeint
gelungen ist war einen kokon gleichsam
gefühlte sicherheit aufzubauen den wir
auch in den folgejahren auch bei der
weiterentwicklung der gemeinsamen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik der
europäischen union gelebt haben wir
haben zwar dann immer wie einzelne
nadelstiche erlebt seine die
terroranschläge auf den auf das eine
oder andere europäische land sei es die
gesteigerte instabilität in europa in
unserem europäischen
sicherheitspolitischen umfeld aber und
zwar professor müller ist auch darauf
eingegangen doch in der eu bei strategie
20 16 zwei jahre nach der annexion der
grimm haben wir uns als eu entschieden
der soft power noch immer das zentrale
instrument unseres handelns sein sollte
nun im lichte des russischen
angriffskrieges auf die ukraine und
start aktion des strategischen kompasses
sehen wir dass die ersten zeiten des
strategischen kompasses schon völlig
anders lauten wir beginnen damit dass
der krieg nach europa zurückgekehrt ist
und wir mit der herausforderung
konfrontiert sind unsere ideale unsere
wertvorstellungen und unsere interessen
entsprechend verteidigen zu müssen wir
sehen also hier im rahmen dieser
strategischen dokumente auch ein
gewisses umdenken das aber auch für uns
als mitgliedsstaat bedeutet dass wir
vielleicht im bereich der sicherheits
und verteidigungspolitik auch hier die
mit diesem wandel einhergehen müssen und
uns auch selbstkritisch die frage
stellen müssen wie sieht es mit unserer
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik aus
und welchen beitrag wollen auch wir als
österreich in dieser geänderten
sicherheitslage entsprechend leisten
zweite schlagwort sicherheit umfassend
denken wir haben viel heute auch am
vormittag gehört und gesprochen von
wirkungsketten
wirkungszusammenhänge die sich aus den
einzelnen risiken ergäben sie haben sie
nur kurz eingeblendet das risikobild
gesehen aber was sie nicht gesehen haben
auf diesem risiko bild wäre hans wir
haben das im ressort natürlich
selbstverständlich in ausarbeitung auch
der zusammenhang dieser einzelnen
risiken und wie sie diese risiken
aufeinander wirken können und das
erscheint oftmals auch in unserer
alltäglichen diskussion für
verwunderlich wenn wir beispielsweise
auch jetzt wenn wir einen strategischen
kompass hier nehmen oder die
französische eu ratspräsident das wird
dort das einen der schwerpunkte auch die
befassung mit dem inter- pazifischen
raum hernehmen für uns als land lockt
erkannt wie inmitten europas der
innovativ ist relativ weit entfernt wir
haben vielleicht nicht das große
augenmerk auf die entwicklungen in
dieser region aber wenn wir und das
wurde heute das thema wirtschaft schon
des öfteren angesprochen in lieferketten
denken wenn wir in die abhängigkeiten
unserer wirtschaft von märkten in dieser
region denken wenn wir nur schauen einen
langjährigen schäfer werner fasslabend
hier an dem über jahrzehnte immer
eingetrichtert hat schau dir die straße
von malakka an durch die 20 bis 25
prozent der am schiff weg beförderten
wirtschaftsgüter durchgehen dann siehst
du die strategische bedeutung dieser
region
ich glaube es muss uns gelingen im
rahmen der sicherheitspolitik hier auch
umfassend zu analysieren und
darzustellen wie hier entwicklungen in
unterschiedlichen regionen der welt auch
uns direkt betreffen und einerseits die
korona pandemie aber auch die ukraine
krise haben uns doch deutlich vor augen
geführt wie verwundbar wie ihr hier sind
weil wir auch als folge der
globalisierung hier abhängigkeiten von
anderen märkten anderen regionen haben
und wir müssen auch wenn wir sind
militärischer sicht oder
verteidigungspolitische sicht sehen das
vielleicht unser bisheriger ansatz auch
mit blick auf die durchgeführten gsvp
missionen oder operationen die immer
sehr menschen einer menschenrechts
basierten intervention logik gefolgt ist
dass wir auch hier vielleicht den fokus
er mit blick auf interessen vitale
interessen und für uns also europa aber
auch für uns als österreich hier
verschieben müssen drittes schlagwort
das sich ihnen mitgeben möchten und es
ist auch sehr eindringlicher sowohl von
katherina reiche also von herbert hier
hier dargestellt worden
gesamtstaatlich denken
wir hans blicke hier auf meine
kolleginnen und kollegen vertreter des
offizierscorps aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
geräte oftmals davon dass wir als
bundesheer das 3 ethische handlungs
reserve der republik sind wir könnten
auch nach der heutigen veranstaltung und
den veranstaltungen in den letzten
jahren wie blick auf die jahresvorschau
feststellen das sieht nicht nur das
strategische handlungsrezepte wir sind
vielleicht auch die vorausschau und
glauben sie mir es macht mich nicht
glücklich und peter vorhofer hat es auch
schon angesprochen dass sich viele der
in den letzten jahres vorschauen
gezeigten risiken dass diese eingetreten
sind so wir sind gut im antizipieren wir
sind dann auch gut unsere leistung zu
liefern wenn andere es nicht mehr können
ich glaube was aber fehlt ist das
dazwischen wir brauchen um die
herausforderungen mit denen wir als
österreich mit denen wir als europa
konfrontiert sind auch die
entsprechenden
permanenten gesamtstaatlichen strukturen
um uns diesen herausforderungen zu
stellen wir müssen wegkommen von dieser
und man gestatte mir den ausdruck ad hoc
schnell kommissionen
sonstige strukturen und verfahren
einzurichten um auf eine krise um auf
konfliktsituationen reagieren zu können
sondern wir brauchen eine permanente
struktur eine permanente befassung mit
all den sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitischen risiken die
ihnen heute am vormittag entsprechend
dargestellt sind und wenn sie genau
geschaut haben und so dass noch vor
ihrem geistigen auge sozusagen haben sie
haben die unterschiedlichen farben
gesehen mit denen die risiken
dargestellt wurden nur die wenigsten
wann rein militärische nichtsdestotrotz
werden wir auch bei den anderen risiken
und herausforderungen als
österreichisches bundesheer als
verteidigungsministerium unseren beitrag
leisten müssen aber gerade die vielzahl
der 54 dargestellten risiken zeigt
deutlich dass wir im gesamtstaatlichen
bereich aber auch wenn wir über die
nationalen grenzen hinaus schauen im
europäischen und internationalen kontext
viel mehr viel besser und viel schneller
zusammenarbeiten müssen um uns diesen
herausforderungen entsprechend stellen
zu können die europäische
sicherheitsstrategie von 2003 wir
vielleicht in einem positiven licht noch
zu die zu zitieren bereits 2003 wurde
richtigerweise in der e s es damals
festgehalten dass kein mitgliedsstaat
allein in der lage sich den damaligen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitischen
herausforderungen
alleine sich denen zu stellen und diese
wirksam zu bekämpfen also ich glaube es
ist höchst an der zeit dass wir hier
auch beginnen im nationalen aber auch im
europäischen und internationalen kontext
hier die entsprechenden strukturen
verfahren und abstimmungen aufzubauen
unser familie borna und
florence entsprechend angesprochen was
wir heute gesehen haben und das sage ich
auch bewusst sein
verteidigungspolitischer direktor ist
noch immer das risikobild zu des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung es ist uns
dankenswerterweise in den letzten beiden
jahren schon gelungen ja auch andere
einflüsse jetzt im positiven sinne hier
mit aufzunehmen aber ich glaube wenn man
von gesamt staatlichen strukturen wenn
man von gesamtstaatlichem verfahren
spricht dann bedarf es auch in der
gesamtstaatlichen lagefeststellung die
dann zu den notwendigen
handlungsanleitungen führt glaube diese
drei punkte werden zentral seien in
einer welt die davon gekennzeichnet ist
dass die krisen zu nehmen die
herausforderungen ansteigen werden und
wie uns auch aus europa vielmehr um
unsere eigenen hausaufgaben kümmern
müssen und uns nicht länger verlassen
können dass andere unsere aufgabe
übernehmen und uns quasi außer obligo
nehmen ich glaube daher dass vielleicht
auch hier in diesem kontext der
russische angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
krise und wir haben sie auch einen
akademischen debatten über jahrzehnte
und sie immer wieder überlegt was ist
jetzt wirklich der trick auch dass wir
es ernst nehmen mit fragen der
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik ich
denke wenn wir die handlungen auch im
rahmen der europäischen union in den
letzten tagen und wochen hier nehmen so
sehen wir doch das gleicht der von uns
in der akademie oftmals erwünschte game
changer eingetreten ist aber und auch
dass er jeder klar gesagt alle
strategischen dokumente alle analysen
die wir so wunderbar produzieren denn
wir meistens immer noch das wort
strategie voran stellen machen wenn sie
vielleicht seinen inhalt nicht immer
sehr strategisch sind all diese
dokumente generieren an sich noch keine
es bedarf auch der entsprechenden
umsetzung es bedarf auch der
entsprechenden implementierung dieser
dieser analysen nicht nur in konkrete
fähigkeiten sondern wie es auch heute am
vormittag angesprochen wurde auch in
unseren köpfen dass wir auch residente
als gesellschaft werden um uns diesen
herausforderungen entsprechend stellen
zu können ich möchte daher an dieser
stelle die gelegenheit wahrnehmen mich
einerseits bei den autorinnen und
autoren der jahresvorschau herzlich für
ihre beiträge zu bedanken seien sie sich
sicher das wird auch im nächsten jahr
wieder in diesem kontext eine
sicherheitspolitische jahres forscher
geben mein besonderer dank gilt ihnen
familie born für die moderation des
heutigen vormittages allen finalisten
und rednern für die interessanten
einblicke die uns am heutigen vormittag
geboten worden sind und die wir auch in
unsere sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitischen analysen
entsprechend zurück fließen werden
lassen um selbst kritisch hier auch
unsere eigene arbeit zu reflektieren
mein größter dank gilt aber ihnen allen
dass sie die zwei fast zweieinhalb
stunden unter diesen verschärften
bedingungen hier ausgehalten haben unser
es blutet mir das herz dass ob der
geltenden corona regelungen wie sie
leider nicht wie normalerweise beim
bundesheer üblich ohne mampf kein kampf
nicht auf eine entsprechende versorgung
im nachgang einladen können es ist der
derzeitige situation leider noch immer
geschuldet aber nichtsdestotrotz ihnen
viel herzlichen dank für ihre zeit für
ihn für ihr interesse bleiben sie uns
gewogen und vor allem viel wichtiger
bleiben sie gesund vielen herzlichen
dank und alles gute
[Applaus]